ladies and gentlemen I have some very
serious news for you today there was an
Insurrection at the capital far-left
extremists in support of Gaza stormed
the cannon building and they were
subsequently arrested uh no one's really
calling it an Insurrection I mean people
are jokingly calling it Insurrection but
yeah like several hundred far leftist
stormed the capital and uh got arrested
but they'll likely get a slap on the
face no serious charges and be let go so
we'll talk about that though because
Rashida T was posting about how Israel
bombed a hospital killing hundreds of
civilians and it turns out that whole
story was a hoax and this is fascinating
because last night we're basically
debating it who did it was it Palestine
was it was it Israel and it turns out it
was nobody I mean technically it was
likely Hamas but it was a parking lot F
no no joke video emerging after the fact
in daylight shows the hospital is still
intact was not leveled was not damaged
for the mo I mean minor damage cosmetic
damage but uh for the most part it looks
like it was a parking lot fire seriously
so the payload from a Hamas rocket
likely fell in the parking lot injuring
civilians not killing hundreds of them
that seems to be overt
propaganda well how about that well
ladies and gentlemen this these lies
caused the the peace mission of Joe
Biden to get canceled in Jordan and now
Joe Biden says he's going to give a $100
million to Gaza that's right uh
basically telling the the uh terrorists
that if they engage in terrorism he's
going to he's going to pay them a lot of
money and that that to me is absolutely
crazy so we'll talk about that before we
get started my friends head over to cast
brew.com if you'd like to buy the best
coffee you've ever had pick up your casw
coffee we've got Appalachian nights dark
roast that's one of our favorites the
number one selling of course is rise
with Roberto Jr our light roast
breakfast blend uh and because there's a
picture of Roberto Jr on it everybody
wants it what can you say uh support the
show by going to casper.com buying your
coffee joining the Casper coffee Club
pumpkin spice is always around but now
it's in season so maybe you want to pick
up some Mr Bokus pumpkin spice
experience we sponsor ourselves we
produce our own coffee because we're not
going to support companies that don't
like our values and we are going to
produce something that we think can be
outside of the normal Media stuff we do
where we can sponsor ourselves with
products when you buy it you're
supporting the show but you can also
support the show directly by going to
timcast.net you are helping the mission
more importantly though you'll get
access to our uncensored membersonly
shows Monday through Thursday and access
to our membersonly Discord where we can
hang out with like-minded individuals
and call into our after show and
actually talk to us so if that's
valuable to you go to timcast.net
of the national libertarian party right
on uh you going to tell us who's running
for president or do we know what's going
on with that or I'll give some updates
on who's running for president and some
other really cool political projects
we're working on oh okay all right right
on well uh that was easy thanks for
hanging out it should be fun we got
Hannah Clair hey I'm Hannah Clair
I'm a writer for timcast.net
from pop culture crisis is here with us
yes hello guys my name is Brett I am the
host of Pop Culture crisis right here on
YouTube Monday through Friday 300 p.m
Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific you should come and hang out
with us and I am here as always
surge.com I'm ready for the episode you
are Tim here we go the first story from
the Daily Mail Pro Palestinian
protesters invade the capital more than
300 demonstrators are arrested after
demanding Israeli ceasefire by staging
sden in a rotunda in the in the Congress
complex look at this I can't believe
what I'm seeing uh this is this is so
dangerous to our democracy what these
people did here uh disrupting an
official proceeding and you know
parading in government building I I
guess 20 years what do you guys think 20
18 lock them up at least 18 for the
leader no trial no we'll just spend two
three years Prosecuting them we'll send
search warrants to their homes we'll
bring them back to DC we'll make them
spend tons of money on legal fees and oh
wait no none of this is going to happen
straight to jail they should have like
somebody should Photoshop in the Q
Shaman in there like someone did that
they did they they they put the shaman
hat on R to or the or the or the old
lady with the American flag that was not
in cap that was oh that was somewhere
else yeah that one really frustrates me
it's so annoying I see high-profile
people be like look at this little old
lady she was it was in Michigan or
something oh wow it's just some random
old lady from a different P like or or
or Oklahoma or something like that cuz
my brain goes she wasn't my brain goes
right to the I like in my brain that her
and like the shaman guy are like right
next to each other at the same time
Capital yeah the little lady with
American flag she was not at the capital
M I mean I could be wrong my
understanding is like that was debunked
a long time ago well January 6 was a
huge disappointment and the
disappointments keep rolling out yeah
but in all seriousness uh uh uh yeah
none of these people should go to jail
for a long period of time I don't care
that they protested in the capital but
we we can see the double standard oh
sure right in front of our in front of
our eyes what's going to happen now is
the left is going to come out first of
all um I think Dave Smith came out and
made this point that you know if you're
calling for them to be arrested it was
the feds who did it was not the leftists
who put you in jail yeah but here's the
problem and I I agree with what he's
saying but this is ex exactly what they
expect yep the libertarian conservative
post liberal faction are going to say no
no don't arrest them because we're good
people and they'll go okay you got it
and then if you fart they'll come and
beat the crap out of you and lock you
for two years because they're not living
by the same agreement right they're
saying we would do it to you but you
shouldn't do it to us and also they feel
justified in what they're doing and that
is sort of never going to go away I I
think the biggest issue is that there's
a two-tier justice system here and it's
obviously obviously Falls around
political we don't play by the same rule
book it's it's a real problem in in the
country hardcore leftists will do
anything and everything by any means
necessary that's how they operate
politically and other people just find
that unsavory and they don't want to
they don't want to throw down that way
and so we're always going to be at that
disadvantage and to the average person
because they don't understand that the
media won't report on it in the same way
it won't be it won't be given equal time
or equal explanation by the media you
won't understand that this is happening
there right now so nobody ends up
finding out nobody who isn't politically
initiated will end up knowing yep I do
think this is good though because the
mask has dropped again and so people who
are on the fence people who are Centrist
who think oh I just don't like the
fighting oh you know XYZ I can't pick a
side it'll help them to really see
what's happening here and why there's
such a disparity and how they should not
be voting for
leftists but I don't think it's enough
to change it to be honest I feel like
this group is going to have the same
supporters no matter what hardcore yeah
uh and ultimately the infighting over
whether or not to support Palestine or
Israel is going to disrupt leftist
communities but I don't know that it'll
ultimately make them abandon the party
right they'll always unite behind
Democrats I think I think hardcore
leftists will will always unite behind
Democrats I'm sure that there are some
people who are sympathetic to leftist
causes and this is a leftist cause even
though you know I'm certainly
sympathetic to anyone who was blown up
by by the Israeli government unjustly
that's that's horrendous but this is by
and large a leftist cause in the United
States and I hope that people can see
that at least the people leading these
these groups in Washington DC are
completely hypocritical but you know uh
there there's two there's two great
stories in our Traditions there is
chicken little and there is um uh the
boy cred wolf yes what happened in
Chicken Little did the sky actually fall
down I think the sky did fall down yeah
the same story like the kid like wolf
and they're like no there's no wolf he's
like there a wolf like oh there's a wolf
no there's no wolf then he's like okay
now there's actually wolf like get out
of here kid and then the Chicken Little
was wasn't it the chicken was like the
skies falling and they like shut up and
they said it again they shut up and then
finally it fell and no one believed him
or something yep yeah whatever I don't
know all I know ising the plot to
Chicken Little right now when Hamas uh
uh runs this narrative Israel blew up a
hospital a press conference is given
where they're like Israel warned the
hospital they were going to do it and
then you get all these leftists
screaming that Israel did it and then
we're like wow I mean you know we in
good faith want to understand who did
this oh and then it turns out nobody did
it I mean look it appears that a Hamas
rocket misfired the payload landed in
the parking lot and created a big fire
the hospital is intact hundreds of
civilians did not die they lied again
these people lie all the time so when
they come out and they're like Israel's
doing evil things I go shut your mes
dude I am so sick of you lying to me to
get me to support War or hundreds of
millions of our dollars being sent to
Gaza at this point I'm just like bro I
don't care I want nothing to do with it
I'm just tired of being lied to by
everybody M this is what they do Rashid
T immediately comes out and claims that
Israel blew up a hospital and people
believe it and then the facts come out a
day later and that's of course oh I mean
it's it's it's considerable damage in
the parking lot there's no crater sure
that's the cars were on fire that's it
do they really even need to exaggerate
isn't there enough chaos and suffering
going on all of it is lies I'm sorry I'm
I'm at the point like they show me these
videos and I'm like gee did an
earthquake happen because they have lied
so much I am done listening to them okay
I'm just I'm I'm fed up I'm just I'm the
the hospital thing was so infuriating
because I see you know like Lukowski
posts why are my tax dollars going to
hitting hospitals because the initial
assumption The Wall Street Journal runs
this headline story that you know uh
blast blows up hospital or whatever and
then it turns out it's like oh wait
here's here's here's video of a rocket
misfire and then we wake up the the
morning and there's footage it's like oh
the parking lot was on fire and they
claimed hundreds died but it's not true
but that story is already out there I
mean you pointed out the Washington Post
put it in their print editional Wall
Street Journal so there are tons of
people who are now always going to be
able to have the image of this headline
and that's ultimately what I think this
is the objective is anyways they it's
not to get truth out there it's to whip
you into a frenzy to support the cause
which is you know one of the grossest
parts of politics in any country but
definitely in America and way worse now
in the like with with war being as the
information around War being as
immediate as it you just you just leak
the story you put the story out there
and yeah sure maybe 5 to 10 20% end up
reading the retraction or see the
follow-up headline but that's a large
amount of people a vast number who will
never know that that's not what happened
here and even if you do print a
retraction I mean the thing about war
reporting is that it's all happening so
fast it's very difficult to verify which
means that as the consumer of it you
should be very uh careful about what
you're seeing and what is being told to
you but people don't do that and so by
the time you know the Wall Street
Journal says oh maybe we got it wrong
actually seven other things have
happened that they've reported on so it
doesn't really matter that never gets
fully cored yeah it's just going to
further and deepen The Divide in the
United States because now you're going
to have a Hardcore team Palestine and a
Hardcore team Israel who believe
different things happen fundamentally
they do not even have the same narrative
which is true of all conflicting causes
but in this case there's no way to go
back and say this was what happened
definitively because the information
that gets circulated I mean this is a
downside of the internet age and the
internet is ultimately you know a huge
blessing in a lot of cases but in this
case it means that it's moving so
quickly you have no way to verify it and
by the time you watch that one video
read that one tweet it's gone and six
other things have replaced it most days
I don't actually think the internet was
a blessing anymore like I don't like
it's as as awful as that sounds like I
don't feel like human beings were
designed to be inundated with that much
information constantly uh especially
when you take into account your life
your work your kids all these things
that take up your time and then you have
these stories which are not light
stories these are not stories about
celebrities or about something in like
cheap in the news this is like really
really life-changing stuff and you're
not designed to be able to take in all
this information endlessly be able to
parse through all the facts and figure
it out they have to rely on people to do
that but we can't rely on the media to
be the ones to do that openly and
honestly this this is the crazy thing
for the entirety of human history up
until the last 80 years or maybe 100
years news was few and far between was
rare or local just very local very local
but barely uh so there was a newspaper
from uh up in Martinsburg I I forgot
where where it was pulled from someone
was telling me about it and it was like
the the one of the front page stories
was that a guy broke his door on his on
his storefront or something like the
newspaper was like Jim broke his door
and you're like oh Jim broke his door
like imagine your community imagine if
your newspaper said like your next door
neighbor's dog got out you'd be like oh
wow that happened again that was news
now it's like every headline news is
like Hitler has returned from the grave
and you know like World War 17 is
happening and they're competing on a
huge scale they need attention from
everyone on Earth it's the same reason
why people are more likely to know who's
running for president than who's
actually running for mayor even though
the mayor makes more decisions about
their town I mean I think you're right
that the Deluge of information is
definitely hindrance for the internet
and I go back and forth sometimes it is
awful but you know the internet allows
me to work the job I have right now the
internet allows tons of families to
homeschool their children effectively
the internet allows people to you know
travel and experience the world while
they work remotely and so as much as I
want to hate the internet all the time
we are past the point of going without
it and there are all kinds of things
that uh suffer when we don't have the
infrastructure for the internet I think
about rural communities that don't have
access to you know hospitals or reliable
um emergency service lines partially
because all of that goes through the
internet but I do got to give it up to
the Internet because imagine what life
was like before it when the government
would put out a statement saying Hamas
has blown up a hospital killing hundreds
of people and you were like wow and that
was it yeah I was talking to a friend
about his family and their view of of
Institutions and their view of
Institutions are that institutions are
absolute and it's kind of crazy like the
general idea is if it's said on TV it is
true period the internet is all fake and
that's the World they but that's like a
lot of people who are voting Democrat
who are watching MSNBC and CNN and I
think it's an older generation too
because the internet was is is more
scary it's not to be as trusted and to
be fair to the internet a lot of crazy
stuff comes up on the internet I mean
it's it is where uh ideas are fleshed
out in a way that they are not in
mainstream media trust the experts right
and and it asks more of you as the
person consuming the information to be
able to make up your own mind about
things I do understand that right like
when I make that statement that's a more
Doomer take on it like look we're just
not but at the same time when it was
just just four news networks deciding
what information you were given you know
then you've put all the power in the
hands of the most elite members of
society who will never have your best
interest at heart I just find that PE
people have talked about how like like
in the age of the internet like we sto
looking at things the way we did before
right like now when you go to look
something up you're hit with so much
that you just at least for like for me I
find that I find it I find it difficult
right to parse through all the
information and if that's difficult when
that's your job it's even more difficult
if you're just somebody who's trying to
stay up on current events while taking
your kids to soccer practice working
your your job that's just it's a lot to
ask of people but with freedom comes the
responsibility to do responsility yeah
it's it's psychologically fatiguing and
it's probably related to why we have so
many anxiety disorders now when we
didn't back in the day you know the day
before the internet there's no way to
unplug but I like having electricity and
all I like electricity for sure air
conditioning that's a good one uh with
the internet though I don't think it's
as addictive as the I mean maybe there
were people who were glued to their TV
definitely when major events were
happening but the internet is addictive
in a way that uh mainstream media and
the traditional television or radio
format is not and that has to do the
fact that it's interactive that you have
sort of personally invested yourself if
you have like a social media profile um
and it means that you constantly want to
be checking in on it whereas at one
point you know the news got boring and
you would turn it off and do something
else yeah let's jump to this story I
have this tweet for you guys from Molly
Hemingway she said I'm so glad I pay
hundreds of a year for this level of
quality in my newspaper front page The
Wall Street Journal blast at Gaza
Hospital kills hundred hundreds hundreds
oh geez what really happened uhoh the
Wall Street Journal posted this one at
6:58 p.m. tonight us experts say
evidence suggest Palestinian rocket hit
Gaza Hospital suggests oh suggest hit
the hospital hit the hospital okay
ladies and gentlemen how about this
article from Tim cast was published well
before the Wall Street Journal who app
apparently just does not want to admit
they were wrong on the front page
because here's the damage it appears to
be the parking lot Oliver Alexander said
IDF Drone footage from the hospital from
after the attack shows damage that is
more consistent with a failed rocket
than a jdam majority of the damage is
concentrated on the car park with no
visible crater we also have uh this
photo right here daylight I mean it's
it's bad okay you know I'm people got
injured in this these cars on fire no
crater the hospital was not leveled it
appears no hundreds of civilians did not
die they lied they lied this is going to
be the first in a long oh yeah long line
of these conflicts it's it's going to be
opportunistic on both sides everybody's
going to be foaming at the mouth
chomping at the bit to take advantage of
any and every little thing that they can
what they what we had we had a super
chat last night and someone said a Hamas
rocket could not level a a building it
had to have been from Israel and I I
immedately said was the hospital leveled
I don't is that is that what like the
whole hospital just collapsed leved
leveled see we go from struck to leveled
yep and the what they were what they
were claiming was that the whole
hospital was hit and collapsed killing
hundreds of people that was the argument
they that would be awful and thankfully
that didn't happen and we should we
should and so I mean this is this is our
fault too I mean we're debating whether
or not whether or not it was Israel or
Palestine and we never stopped to ask
whether it really happened or not it's
really difficult to figure it out just
like we were looking at that image of
Rashida T earlier wearing the Qing on
Shaman hat trying to figure out is it a
deep fake or not and and it's fake but
things things make it out into the
internet really quickly and everybody
has an agenda that they're trying to
push I mean the agend the internet's the
biggest game of telephone of all time
the agenda I want to push is that the
United States should stay out of it
financially yeah I do too yeah I at this
point especially but the but now Biden
wants to give him a $100 million so just
justifying the ter the Biden
Administration is trying to make both
sides happy and they will proceed to let
everyone down because they also issues
they're like we are issuing sanctions
against several members and entities
affiliated with Hamas so they are trying
to cover all their bases this is not
going to work the only option really
would be to not get involved but of
course they're just making us more
involved in ways that are so complicated
and are obviously going to backfire
Biden's going to strengthen his Base by
pumping money into any cause he can
related to helping Palestine and leftist
activist meanwhile conservatives in the
United States are going to scream for
Israel and to dump more the United
States dollars into Israel we already
give them billions of dollars we should
just stop giving everyone money we just
thoughts and
prayers like we're not the world's ATM
we the reason we give them money is so
they spend it that's it yeah we want you
you give 100 million dollars to a
handful of world leaders they will live
like kings and spend that meaning we
will do the labor on their behalf cuz
what do you get what what do you buy
with US Dollars things from people who
take US dollars for the most part as
American citizens
but then it circulates in their
countries or that that wealth that we
produce is shifted off to their country
these world leaders then agree to use
the Petro dollar and this is the game
that's being played yep y not everywhere
though some not everywhere yep some
people are saying they've had enough and
I don't know whether that's going to
play yep I don't know if that's going to
be good or bad for us but it is
happening isn't isn't it kind of funny
that around the same time the bricks
nations are announcing their own
currency and several nations are
announcing they're going to stop trading
in US dollars or they're going to start
trading in one World War II seems to be
breaking out yep how convenient we've
got 19,000 Personnel in the
Mediterranean just outside of of Israel
we've got 2,000 uh uh more ready to be
deployed Yep they're saying the Pentagon
is PR preparing them to go on the ground
potentially yeah I I I I look the
embassy in the the US Embassy in Lebanon
has set on fire last night yeah so sad
they needed they need to cast his belly
so like okay so you're saying that like
uh supporting Hamas will strengthen his
base what is the size of assuming he got
81 million votes right what's the size
of his base and do we really is is it
really believable like is that mostly
people supporting Palestine he's Biden's
going to lose from this I mean I don't
think it's a good it doesn't it doesn't
make sense to me like I I have a lot of
friends who are they're they're
political they're they're they're
Democrats whatever fine but they're not
they're not here supporting him El right
now well not everyone who's Pro
Palestine is pro Hamas it's they're two
different things they're related but I
think that you I would hope that a lot
of people who are wanting USA to go and
support Palestinians who are suffering
they don't want to support terrorists
even if I disagree with them I don't I
don't think that they necessarily want
to see terrorism supported but look the
reality is that part of Biden's base are
the same class of people who donate to
institutions like Harvard and we are
seeing that those donors are pulling
their dollars he's hurting either way
there's no no positive move it's not a
good move I understand the argument that
Palestine is not Hamas but I do kind of
think that's a bit naive because if
you're if if Joe Biden says I'm going to
give a $100 million to the people of
Palestine we know where that money is
really going it's going to get
confiscated by Hamas confiscated or just
given to them they're the government in
Gaza they will just take it and it's
also basically saying if you engage in
ter even if the money was was
specifically given to Nos and it
resulted in people getting cleaner water
and buildings and air conditioning and
and other things they they need then
Hamas is basically told like well
whenever you need money when you want
money for your people whether it goes to
you or not all you got to do is go kill
thousands of isra it's a terrible
precedent absolutely and and so when it
comes to these people who are like we we
we defending Palestine it's okay well
the Palestinian people vote for vote for
Hamas not all of them though no but but
the point is there there that you you
can argue for civilians that I totally
get but the government stands in the way
and what is the solution then the
solution is the United States has got to
stay out of it I completely agree so but
people who say I'm that want to support
Palestine no there's no way to support
one cre get creative I haven't figured
out how to do that no no we can we can
stop supporting uh all of it Al together
or you can support all of it like the
idea that you can support the
Palestinian people and not be supporting
Hamas is incorrect I know I'm not saying
you are directly funding and allowing
Hamas to engage in what they're doing
but what you give when you donate to
these groups will find its way to
empowering Hamas former Congressman
Justin Amash uh his family was
Palestinian Palestinian Christians and
they were sponsored over here by
Christian missionaries so I don't know
how easy or challenging that is
currently but that's one way to try to
help people is get them out of that
situation trying to leave that I that I
can that's what the first minister of
Scotland is saying today he said
Scotland will take refugees from be
careful who you invite into your country
and that that's it I mean when you've
got I think the latest numbers that we
pulled up a couple days ago was like uh
Hamas won the election with like 44% or
something I don't I'm I'm not an expert
in the region but 44% is I mean that's
that's like the margins we get for
presidents in this country I don't I'm
not going to blame everybody for Joe
Biden the people who voted for Joe Biden
are to blame but you you you you
have it's Inseparable right there there
is going to be in any material support
to Gaza material support going towards
Hamas sure it's just like live a when
they when politicians and celebrities
and musicians everybody got together to
to pump money into Africa it went to
African Warlords it didn't go to the
people who needed it this is true for
for anywhere we give money this includes
Israel yeah absolutely when we when we
when we give money to donate to Israel
you are strengthening the economy and
the structure and the infrastructure of
Israel which ultimately can run up to
the IDF to the Israeli government I am
not saying that is right or wrong for
either I'm saying they're Inseparable so
that there's I'm frustrated by the
people who are like we don't we don't
like what Hamas is doing we support the
Palestinian people and it's like well
the plurality of the voters support
Hamas and Hamas just massacred a bunch
of civilians and now our government's
giving them more money I got a simple
solution cut it off I think like no no
more no more funding the best thing that
we could do is try to try to facilitate
peace talks it's not gone well in the
past that's that's about it that's and
that's and that's the thing it's like
look man there's no easy answer here
yeah I see what what I see here with
this conflict is really exemplified by
what we see with the left
where these leftists are cheering for
death a lot of them are yeah I mean when
they post a picture of a paraglider it's
gross they're celebrating death
absolutely no question and maybe there's
the banality of evil in the morons on
the left who have no idea what actually
happened and are just waving the flags
and raising the fist but when these
groups organize an outright issue
statement saying they're Freedom
Fighters when the professor said that
professor said settlers are not
civilians they will lie to your face as
they've done they will cheer for death
and then we are supposed to sit back and
be like let's be reasonable here guys
let's make sure we're helping the
civilians like no no no dude dude
they're lying to you and they're
committing the people Hamas is killing
people I'm not saying Israel is innocent
I'm not saying any country in war there
there's there there's always some some
Nuance in the conflict there's always
collateral damage it's it's never good
but I'm just sick of being lied to and
when you look at what the left says and
does they cheer for your death and they
lie about being victims so it's just
like stop just stop the Israeli
government does not treat people well
over there but there's no that doesn't
justify murdering people with
paragliders and it's really unfortunate
that people on both sides no one will
just admit murder is wrong so so when
when we have this video that comes out
um and we had we had Max blumthal and
he's talking about the march of return
okay Palestinians peacefully marched to
the fence with their hands up and Israel
still shot at them okay that that's the
kind of story you're like oh wow I mean
like that that sounds really bad why
would they do that well here's the
question I have I'll ask you as I ask
anybody if Israel removed all of the
security perimeter around Gaza and told
the people of Gaza there free to move
through Israel what would
happen oh wow I mean you'd see a lot of
different mixed reactions there but I
think you'd see violence you be
Massacre by who I mean both sides I
assume I doubt the the old ladies and
the kutzas are going to pick up guns and
go charge not old ladies no what likely
would happen is there's going to be a
bunch of fighting AE young men mainly
Hamas substantially more than we saw
actually paraglide because paragliding
is difficult and more expensive and they
would Rampage through the kabes The
Villages make their way to Tel Aviv and
start just massacring people with rifles
I think you'd probably see some Israelis
who angry doing similar things yes but
the Israelis aren't going to storm into
Gaza if the if the security barrier of
Gaza was removed Israeli citizens are
not going to run full speed into Gaza to
start massacring people yeah it's
defensive versus offensive I think
they're missing that I mean so there was
this Irish politician who I saw a clip
of talking about how I think his name is
Paul Murphy talking about how people
should he he's Pro Palestine or I mean
you could I don't know if you would
argue that he's pramas but he's saying
that this is not a conflict between
equals because uh Israel is
significantly more financial and militar
Advantage but I don't
think that may be true on the other hand
the solution being like we should have
peace talks is almost to me INE
ineffective because there's no peace
between these two people they will they
have been in Conflict for a long time
and Israel has been you know has taken
aggressive moves in in their own steps
and Palestine and Hamas have responded
in turn I mean what would peace possibly
look like between these two don't think
ever
I think the best you can do Never back
down I mean I I don't think that there's
any from what I know and I've been
trying to research this more for for
Palestinians there is no compromise
because they always feel like they are
getting the short on the stick the best
you could do is try to negotiate a
two-state solution I don't think that
there will ever be peace in the Middle
East but I think that it's possible we
could deescalate this and there would be
less death there will never be a
two-state solution when one side says no
and from The River To The Sea well both
sides are saying no right now yeah but
one side says from the river to the Sea
like the left that stormed that Capital
they're they're chanting for the
eradication of Israel Patrice cers of
BLM 2015 said and Israel outright so if
we're going to Israel and saying like
what can we do to stabilize the region
with a two-state solution Israel has an
open door for negotiation I'm not saying
they're innocent didn't a lot of people
in Hamas didn't they didn't they write
in their Charter that they wanted to go
back to like 1967 agreement and have a
two-state solution so so the issue I
want to be arguing for Hamas it feels
gross yeah I mean Hamas original charter
said the eradication of Israel and and I
I think it might have specifically
referred to the Jews themselves right
and then it was amended I think in 2017
to tone that language down probably
because they knew they relied on
International support but those people
sentiments don't change the the the
issue is I don't care who you support
the issue is there are two ideologically
opposed groups yeah there is one
chanting from The River To The Sea okay
like the other one's just saying just
saying it quietly maybe Israel I I I I
don't know if there is a slogan of
Israel to chant other than we've seen
some people say they want to Glass Gaza
or something like that that's quite
intense I don't know if the government
is outright coming out and saying those
things it seems to be the the the
Israeli government understands the
nuances of international relations and
is trying at the very least we can say
this whether they are or not they're
putting on the front of we try to
minimize civilian casualties and we are
only responding we are not
instigating so when you have war between
two factions and one side wins there is
no solution where you're just like well
no I I I understand these are Waring
factions with deep ideological tensions
going back thousands of years but let's
just let's just have peace it's like
well certainly not that's very naive
it's it's never going to happen that's
very naive I I just I'm looking at this
and I'm like well Hamas just lied about
everything I mean they they paraglides
into uh into Israel and they started
killing civilians killing children and
that is their their their mil their
their their uh military Doctrine kill
civilians and capture civilians is part
terrible so how do we have peace with
that we don't have peace with Hamas but
weas is so intrin the rest the rest of
the people in Palestine I feel would
really love to have peace talks be a
thing I I think I think that's not true
I think that's then the the answer would
be for Israel to invade Gaza and excise
Hamas and then restore Democratic
institutions to the reigning individuals
guess what they will not accept that the
other Arabic Nations have outright
threatened that if Israel does that it's
going to escalate so that's not going to
happen and then Israel's other answer is
air strikes on Hamas targets which
results in massive collateral damage so
we're stuck with an open air stop
funding any of it us should not be
involved in an unsolvable problem the
the one who and then another group that
loses is the American people as more of
our tax money is funded into it I think
we should absolutely I think one of the
ways that you might see a better outcome
in this is if we stopped giving Israel
United States money here's the the
argument Ben airo made which is not
without its Merit I don't completely
agree is that Israel will not allow
itself to cease to exist it will not
allow defeat and it and it is considered
what the fourth strongest military it is
also widely speculated they have nuclear
weapons yeah the Samson option is if
Israel is facing extermination they will
use nukes to defend themselves okay if
the US does not make every attempt to
stabilize the conflict it will devolve
into World War II that's basically what
Ben argument was if Israel invades Gaza
now and then Iran responds Syria and
Lebanon respond and then Israel gets
overwhelmed from external forces without
us support Israel fires a nuke on Iran
Iran retaliates the region lights up
pulling in a bunch of different nations
leading to a wides scale if if at the
very least a regional Annihilation worst
case World War II so it's up to Team
America World Police to step in that's
the argument from tell everyone yeah my
argument is the US intervention itself
exacerbates that problem in the exact
same way absolutely and there is no
solution other than we're walking full
speed as fast as we can into World War
II I don't think there's going to be
ever like a a literal peace in the
Middle East I think we could see maybe
less conflict and I would love for them
to give that a try and removing our
money is the first step in that there is
one path towards
peace well there's actually two the the
the the path towards piece that we hope
for is generational uh um uh proximity
leading to a generational deescalation
yep as more and more of these people
grow up in these areas and want nothing
to do with the conflict they just to
live better lives and the old ideas and
traditions Fade Away they'll start to
say like why why why were my great-
grandparents fighting you like I I don't
want to have anything to do with them
man just please leave me alone so one of
the things that helps uh uh helped
racism kind of dissipate in the United
States was proximity people growing up
next to people of other races is being
like we are friends like everything they
said about that guy was not true and so
it removes those stigmas and stereotypes
we could also remove sanctions on Iran
and kind of just leave the rest of the
Middle East alone and stop engaging in
regime change every now and then that
would probably help I don't think that's
going to I I I all that that won't
stabilize the region I think I think it
would stop destabilizing it so much I I
think before the United States was in
Afghanistan you had the Soviets there
and the and and and then we we back the
muad de because we're it's a proxy war
so whether it's us China or Russia there
is going to be foreign
influence manipulating and you and and
and fighting over the Middle East I'm
not saying I have a good solution I'm
just saying that it seems that we are
facing with with thousands of years of
ideological hatred there the two
solutions would be can we just do
everything in our power to try and
stabilize this so that over a long
period of time the fighting calms down
maybe not especially when you see the
the the children in gazar being taught
explicitly
they hate us ha hate us and Israel the
other solution is the one that nobody
likes to admit but is in all sci-fi the
Trope of what the AI does to bring about
peace wipe out humans well I mean that
seems a little maybe a bit much that's
the extreme instance yeah there's peace
when there's no one left yeah I think I
think we could not do that I I think you
know that our the goal is to avoid that
from happening and that is the the the
terrifying outcome of if we can't solve
the problem our involvement in the in
the Middle East has just been an
absolute failure since the Iraq War
since Desert Storm really well before
that I mean since since the muhaj Haden
well I mean going I mean look Iran sure
the Irani Revolution yeah absolutely and
even the idea of proximity doesn't
necessarily bear itself out to work
because we may have had that at a
certain period of time but then the kids
go to college and they learn all the
things that they learn now which teach
you to hate your neighbor rather than to
actually Le to understand them so I
don't know as as information is freely
passed from generation to generation if
that is something that's going toen it's
going to take an excessively long period
of time and as long as military action
is still happening in the interim you
create new enemies with every new
military action students here hate the
Second Amendment in guns so you know
that's not that's not well I don't know
about woke the farle likes guns yeah
it's the liberals who don't the Liberals
don't uh yeah the left loves gun left is
college students here I would say they
don't like guns it is also funny that
you mention I don't know about that you
think they like guns yeah leftists like
guns they have they have like the Red
Guard they have the social they have the
John Brown Gun Club but I think leftist
college students are unique partially
because of the impact that the Parkland
school shooting had that was like one of
the big high school to college
push I don't think
so Vos is pro gun all of the high
schoolers that I worked with who are now
in college he's a a prominent leftist
with hundreds of thousands of followers
and he's 26 he's a he's a small Dem he
represents a small demographic of gun
loving leftists I I think you're wrong
the left the leftists love guns it's the
LI it's it's the average liberal that
hates the guns now there there's far
less there's far less of your gun owning
Blue Dog Democrats than there was before
and the rest have been turned by the
media by Hollywood by all these places
to be extremely anti-gun because they
read articles every day that says
there's been 90 school shootings today
um in all these things it is funny that
you mentioned Team America World Police
because that movie you know I I mean
actually when you think about the people
that made back then might have been more
libertarian but it would have been
Hollywood back in the day that would
have been very like uh America needs to
stop intervening in these foreign
conflict maybe we'll get another one you
know except this time it seems more like
instead of just stay out it's just give
everybody money you know so which is
never going to work that's the most
ridiculous solution of all time Team
America World Bank basic so let's let's
let's yeah let's pull up this story from
the post-millennial Hamas leader says
the same type of racism that killed
George Floyd is being used by Israel
against the Palestinians where is that
quote I want to I want to hear
the
Floy
Floyd right that makes Israel the the
Derek shauvin of of the world they just
know Floy I I you know what I I all
right if that's his argument I agree
George Floyd was chewing on a speedball
behind the wheel of a car the police
officers were trying to stop him because
what he was doing could result in the
death of children and himself he begged
to be released from the car and then was
placed on the ground with a lethal
amount of various drugs in his system
officers were trying to subdue him as he
was screaming and resisting eventually
he ended up up dying now should they
have had their their Shin had his knee
on his back for nine plus minutes maybe
not maybe they should have got no they
shouldn't have he should have gotten a
medical attention immediately the dude
was dying presumably due to well I think
the official reporting is that it was
Cardiac Arrest due to pressure but let's
just say the dude had a this is also a
fact he had lethal amounts of I think
Fentanyl and other drugs in his system
including meth so if this guy is arguing
that they're just like George Floyd it's
like okay so you're saying that you're
like chalk full of crazy crazy ass drugs
and you're engaging in behaviors that's
putting yourselves and others at risk
and now Israel is trying to stop you
from doing that that didn't work the way
you thought here's the argument should
George Floyd have been allowed to have
chew a speedball and drive an SUV
certainly not no police should the
police have made an attempt to stop him
from doing it yeah what do you think
you're more libertarian oh man what was
happening when that went down he was
sitting behind the wheel of the SUV
presumably in a drug deal what we thing
happened is that when the cops came up
he started chewing on the speedball spit
it out on the floor crazy amount of
drugs in the system they removed him
from the vehicle and asked him to sit
down then they were going to bring them
to their SUV for an arrest should they
have done that or should have they just
should they have just said just stay in
the vehicle and do your drugs if they
have probable cause they pull them out
so the problem with the George Floyd
story then is they handled it
irresponsibly when they when they held
him on the ground absolutely in the in
the body cam footage George Floyd is say
put me on the ground put me on the
ground put me on the ground over and
over again and so they agree to chovin
shows up later not knowing what's going
on and then puts his knee his knee is
around the neck and the upper back uh
it's widely disputed they then call uh
medical which arrives no n so minutes
later in the def in the in the in the
criminal trial for
Chauvin the uh uh use of force expert
for the prosecution said chovin used a
lower amount of force than was
authorized
locking up locking him up was clearly
political he was authorized to actually
tase George Floyd which is an escalation
of force and chose not to yeah what he
did was it's still the wrong Force it's
still the wrong Force it's less Force
but it's dangerous and irresponsible put
your knee on someone's neck that's the
argument was it's disputed whether or
not it was actually on his neck or not
sure it like was it was it on his back
so the issue is if someone is engaging
in behavior that could result in death
are you to blame if you engage in
actions that tried to stop them from
committing violent acts so if a guy I
say has a gun and he's on drugs and he's
and he's holding that gun yeah and he's
waving it around yeah and then you tell
him to drop it and then he staggers
about Falls over and then you're like
hey man this guy's going to shoot
somebody then he raises the gun up at
you and you shoot him should you go to
jail I just don't think it's comparable
to what's going on over there you know
unfortunately this Hamas leader just
totally shot himself in the foot with
this awful argument well this is my
point the argument being made by Hamas
is that they are drug addicts engaging
in extremely dangerous behavior that
will kill others and themselves and
Israel is trying to stop them well but
he mostly said it just to invoke
sympathy for white people no but I'm I'm
going to give it to him I'm going to
give it to him you're going to give it
to him well I think it's unfortunate
that everyone in Palestine is getting
caught up in his awful awful argument
what if the people in Palestine I don't
know like rose up and like captured and
arrested all of the Hamas people and
said stop doing this that would be
amazing why aren't they doing that I
think they're terrified of Hamas so they
vote for and some of them I mean when
liby on the other day she was saying one
of the things Hamas did was offer social
services so some people have a
relationship with Hamas that at one
point was in some ways positive even if
the things they're doing now are
negative it's a very complicated
relationship some of them I'm sure are
deeply resentful and also feel tied to
it it's like a it's like a battered
battered husband battered wife
relationship probably someone over there
is is essentially held hostage and there
are ultimately always going to be
Palestinians who feel as though Israel
is in the wrong for being there at all
absolutely even if they're not
sympathetic to us they don't want to
dispute the land they feel entitled to
yeah one of the first things I saw after
the initial air strike uh after Israel's
first uh initial air strike was that it
was the picture oddly enough of uh it
says this is what it looks like after
Israel um dropped bombs on Gaza and he
says just kidding this is Minneapolis
after the George Floyd riots in 2020 so
that actually ties those together even
more yeah because it looked almost the
same because Minneapolis was a destroyed
as the same way that we might know the
names of you know some random people
that come out of social movements in
other countries I really just think that
there is no understanding of the
implications of what invoking George
Floyd mean other than it makes leftists
in America sympathetic to your cause
because they believe it's a racial
argument um in fact all the leftists in
America probably have no idea what the
Nuance situation is they know there are
certain sides you're supposed to fall on
and they're attempting to we don't
really fully understand what it's like
to vote in an election where part of
your the dominant faction of your
government is essentially a terrorist
organization what are the implications
of arguing against them what how what
happens when you come out vocally
against Hamas in Palestine that's not
something that we really understand over
here actually a lot of them probably
would say that about the American
government right they they would
actually say that like say about we vote
for an election here in America we're
voting for a terrorist faction they
would say that about us that's what I'm
saying like they would they would take
that position the same way that people
here are taking that position when they
talk about Palestinians voting for you
know a big difference here though is
that when our when our government
engages in atrocities it's overseas it's
not in like Mexico at least not yet you
know we haven't we haven't elected
anyone yet who's saying that they're
going to go to war in Mexico although we
we should man because the border is weak
we should not go to do we want
I'm just kidding although I do think we
should secure the Border I mean there is
obvious Conflict at the border and there
is obviously a level that could be
classified as an invasion and we don't
do anything about it in fact we are only
interested right now in spending money
abroad in Ukraine and Israel in in
Palestine and although humanitarian you
want to offer support to those who are
suffering especially those you might
consider your ally we are not ultimately
putting the people of Texas of Arizona
and the after that Hawaii also the
northern borderers poor it's gotten
worse and worse and worse so people of
Upstate New York people of Vermont
people of Maine we put them last in this
scenario and that's ultimately the US
government's biggest failing in this
situation that's the most annoying part
like Hawaii wasn't that long ago like
are are our attention spans and our
memories that short that uh in between
you know our ninth funding of Ukraine
and what happened between Israel and
Palestine is that we had several things
uh East Palestine here all sorts of
things are happening here that are tax
dollars what did they get $700 in Hawaii
per household or something not even per
person not even right so like there's
plenty of things that our tax dollars
could be used here in America and I
think that that does resonate with the
average person I'd like to believe that
the average person who's saying like
look I just want to see that the less
nuanced position of like I just want
everybody I'm voting for peace I want
peace what they also mean is like like
we need to focus on what's going on here
there's plenty to do here and I don't
think that's even like people are
calling that isolationism I don't think
it's isolationism it's just purely
trying to to make something happen
your is isolationism bad
is isolationism would mean that we're
not engaging in free trade having
diplomacy exactly which why it's saying
it's not
isolation
recogniz the thing is we just do crazy
things when we're on the global stage
we're not consistent and I just don't
know it's not that I think we shouldn't
engage in free trade but ultimately the
idea that we have to be involved in
everything everywhere all the time does
not serve the American people a hint a
whisper of isolationism please and well
and like look if you're going to uh help
somebody else you have to help yourself
first you need to like on a
plane secure your mask first before you
help someone else we can do with helping
ourselves first but I but I think what
many people fail to realize is that this
argument is is essentially like the
chickens in the chicken cpop complaining
that we only buy certain feed and why
are we spending money outside of the
chicken coop we take their eggs they're
paying their taxes and then they're like
hey you realize that people who run this
show are wasting our food and resources
on other houses and other chicken coops
like what's this all about yeah the
chickens have no Authority their say
means nothing so we sit here and we're
like the American people are upset about
what's going on bro since the end of
World War II International interests
have been have superseded us interests
the purpose of of the Petro dollar the
international monetary fund visa and
MasterCard what the American people want
is immaterial to what the massive
International institutions are trying to
do and what they want I hope more and
more people shift their buying power
their savings out of the US dollar and
into Bitcoin we I think that we need to
starve the banks uh oh Elizabeth warr's
going to put you on a list I
know yeah but maybe they want Bitcoin
well they don't get it that's just not
how Bitcoin works that's how other
cryptocurrency might work they can get
into that but not in Bitcoin well why
why not what do you think well you can't
print Bitcoin into Oblivion you buy it
all oh can you other people own it
right you buy from them we don't know
who all owns it so the US government
when when if they're really concerned
about Bitcoin look I like Bitcoin I
think bitcoin's good I have Bitcoin but
if the US government's really concerned
about Bitcoin with $33 trillion in debth
yeah they could buy out Bitcoin I don't
know about that I think that good that's
the the only way they couldn't is that
some people would not sell there you go
but that's not enough there's a lot of
people who really really hate the US
dollar who own a lot of Bitcoin there's
a lot of wealthy people in Dubai who
have a lot bin coin too and see in the
interest of the United States to buy as
much Bitcoin as possible but they're not
doing it they want they're they're
they're too hubristic they're too H
perhaps but I kind of think they they
would and this is the argument that I
made to a bunch of my Anarchist and
libertarian friends if you were a uh say
like a Council on Foreign Relations or
something like that and you believed in
some kind of like liberal economic order
you're trying to create so that you
could control the flow of currency
around the world what you what you need
is a universal trade the US dollar is
great but doesn't penetrate literally
everywhere we do pretty well with it
right so you want a One World Currency
you want everyone using the same
currency well how do you go about doing
that every time you bring up something
like a multinational currency or an
international currency all these
crackpot conspiracy theorists
Libertarians and anarchists start losing
their minds I got an idea what if we
seed them into promoting our Universal
Global Currency and get them to be the
ADV advocates for it true there's an
idea so the first thing we'll do is we
will create a digital currency that
tracks everything you do so we'll know
every purchase you make we'll we'll be
able to track it publicly and openly you
won't be able to hide it because bit
it's not it's not Monero it's not zcash
it's Bitcoin and then what we'll do is
we'll go to all the Libertarians and
tell them hey this is anti-government
money Meanwhile we're the ones secretly
holding the bul of it and they won't be
able to track it because we have the
machines and we know the plan and they
don't then you get a bunch of
Libertarians being like I'm going to buy
this up they get really wealthy off of
it start advocating for it to be the
thing to buy but Bitcoin if you're using
it for transactions everything you do is
tracked
publicly that's surveillance State 101
but it's so safe Tim everyone's so safe
look I like Bitcoin I like Bitcoin
there's a lot of great things about it I
like crypto in general I don't like
crypto in general I think that it opens
the door for Central Bank digital Curren
I was joking about being safe isn't safe
for the government they're taking care
of us all think there's a big difference
between Bitcoin and and general definit
there is the main challenge with Bitcoin
is that everything you do is publicly
tracked and the government will always
know every purchase you've ever made and
they want to get rid of cash and it's
Libertarians advocating for switching
over to a completely digital currency
that is tracked by the government no no
no no no no no no I'm not advocating for
switching over completely I'm saying we
need I'm not saying I'm saying the
Libertarians
are massively advocating for well sure I
mean I say the Liber libertarian party
has the official position that everybody
should adopt Bitcoin but it's
overwhelmingly the Libertarians who who
made Bitcoin successful it's good I'm
holding out I don't think it's the
government I think that this is this is
a smart move and we need to diversify
and get off the do you think the Bitcoin
is accessible to the average American
meaning
like what kind of financial literacy do
you need to have to be able to get into
Bitcoin because I think there are a lot
of people who get air they hear these
stories about malfunctions or whatever
else and they get scared of Bitcoin I
think probably a good eight hours of
learning about it that's more than we
get in high school in America just a
good a good8 hours and you probably
could figure out how to use it safely do
you think that everybody should be using
it as their day-to-day currency not yet
but eventually maybe we need to we need
to make it easier to use lightning
Network and things like that so yet
aren't those components of it more
centralized though and run by like big
Tech Guys in Silicon Valley no no that
no I don't think that people should be
using major uh trading platforms if that
if that makes sense I think people need
to be a little bit safer when they use
it the challenge is the reason why
Bitcoin forked so many times is because
large portions of the community disagree
with each other and and it's it's direct
democracy so what happens is 51% of the
people running Bitcoin decide a rule
change comes into effect and then just
boot out the other 49 who now still will
have that forked currency but that
creates Bitcoin cash and like you know
all these other derivatives of Bitcoin
because people disagree with the the
changes being implemented by the
majority it's it's okay that there's
some choice in currency sure yeah uh
that's why I think bitcoin's good but I
don't know if I believe in this like
total Bitcoin world I don't I don't
don't get me wrong I don't think it
needs to be total Bitcoin world I think
this is a good way to push back against
the US dollar but so so so what what
world is that is that some of the trade
we do is in Bitcoin some of it is in
dollars I think well it doesn't even
necessarily have to be US Dollars you're
going to have to push off of the dollar
and push against it and see what happens
what do you trade with
right now you've got Bitcoin people are
also they still have gold and silver you
know there are gold bugs out there I'm
not so you're not trading with gold and
silver right the the value of gold and
silver is too great based on it weight
so you could do the gold backs for
instance but then it's just like people
look at your side i' like you're giving
me a polymer enclosed gold foil bill is
this let's got the pirates and their
deons let's move more onto Bitcoin and
see what happens with the dollar my
biggest concern is that to weaken the
Federal Reserve uh and I I agree with
that but my concern about Bitcoin is
that you're the government will be able
to track everything you do I think it's
a little Doomer they can already track
everything we do yeah but not when you
buy things in cash or the very least it
depends on how large of a transaction it
is in cash yeah even then because going
into a bank it's being tracked and and
Banks aren't even giving out certain
deposits but uh you know if you go buy
something even 10 grand in cash it's you
have a choice of whether you're
following the law or not like my
attitude is like just pay your taxes but
there is a bit more leeway in so I'll
put it this way Moxy Marlin Spike made a
great point about why why some there
needs to be room for people to commit
illegal acts yeah and the argum he made
was
marijuana everybody right now is
starting this is years ago I interviewed
him he said people are start we're
starting to see the legalization of
recreational and medicinal marijuana but
how would people know they wanted it
legal if they never tried it there has
to be a little bit of give in the system
otherwise it only Flows In One Direction
and I'm like that's actually completely
correct if Things become illegal and
then you are prevented from ever seeing
it or hearing or touching it eventually
we all live in Gray boxes we don't own
anything and everything's illegal there
has to be a way to push back and test
the boundaries and be like wait wait
actually this shouldn't be illegal so
the challenge with Bitcoin is that I see
everything you do will be completely
tracked and is and not just by the
government but by any other nefarious
actors and foreign governments well you
can use Monero if you're uncomfortable
with Bitcoin that's why I like crypto
not just Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin itself
is good so much out that's so bad though
in yeah but that's like saying you know
I bought a you know uh pyite and it
turned out not to have been gold I got
scammed it's like okay well you know
someone scammed you yeah that doesn't
mean gold is bad you know so crypto I
like I think we agree
yeah all right well how about we uh we
jump to uh another story here I want to
bring up this one Beauty Tycoon Huda
Katan faces Furious backlash and boycott
threats to her makeup line after sharing
anti isra video on Instagram I don't
know who this is do you guys know who
Huda Katan is yeah she has a really
popular makeup line especially when this
this will mean nothing to the boys in
the room but you might get it uh baking
which is where you put a lot of like
setting powder under your eyes and then
brush it off she was one of the had a
really popular product for that and
she's carried in Sephora Ulta things
like that um she she has gotten in
trouble for similar things before but
obviously now the timing makes
everyone's moves more heightened um I
know people often say you know you
shouldn't you should cancel her and they
do this with other makeup companies so
another one was Anastasia Beverly Hills
apparently the founder had some Pro
Russian statements when there the
Ukraine stuff was happening so they have
great product what everyone needs to
understand here is that this uh this
famous celebrity woman who sells makeup
is willing to burn everything down
around her to support
Gaza good for her and people on the
right are too busy saying I can't speak
up no I can't take the risk sorry oh but
you know it's just it's it's you know I
can't do it there you go so long as
that's the case they're going to they're
going to continually gain ground now to
be fair for for a variety of reasons I
think this is actually like my my point
here is about the conviction of the left
their willingness to destroy everything
to get what they want people have to
take risks you have to be able to be a
political risk taker but that being said
I think she'll just end up losing a ton
of money and her her brand will start
fizzling she might or this might blow
over in a week on that's what happens in
the past she cuz she's she's a US Iraqi
Citizen and she said stuff that people
get upset about but the boycotts never
last as long as she has ownership of her
company Kat Von D got in trouble for
saying some uh very not P things uh
having some strange um marketing for her
cosmetics and she ended up getting she
sold her company but she was almost
pushed out was that was recently though
right like not that long ago a couple
years ago years ago I think she just got
baptized
oh she had a huge she's on an arc right
now we actually just talked about this
today it's amazing she a couple weeks
ago yeah amazing to watch her get her
tattoos blacked out and to be for
medical freedom and moved to where is
she Ohio
Ohio
house he's been um I follow all these
guys cuz I have a Cosmetics line too but
get this you do I do it's called bonaa
Cosmetics no way absolutely are you guys
on Public Square so I'm in
pre-production I've been in
pre-production since May what made you
want to do this I made it for real women
by
women actual women if you catch my drift
yeah I get you um the there a a Sephora
just wasn't there a SE like somebody
who's like a Maga supporter who was like
Sephora or Ulta and she was like
sponsored by them and they got rid of
her because of stuff she said like did a
video like with prageru or something
like a year ago I wouldn't be surprised
but I don't know that story specifically
I mean Ulta was one of the big um Dylan
Mulan girlhood podcast basically started
a Cosmetics line to push back against it
and said we're only using real women as
makeup models no deal in M people were
very offended they were like what about
your transp friends I was like well I'm
not upset with them you know but we have
to push the Overton window in a certain
direction and so this is the stand that
I'm taking we're going to make women's
products I'm coming up with tampons and
things like that too it's crazy how now
like you have to like it's all
whataboutism like Victoria Secret like
Victoria Secret saying like they're like
you need to have people who aren't super
hot too they're like why can't they why
can't you just be like no we don't like
you can do that we don't we don't need
to do that let's just have young
attractive models showing off products
and and that's okay hasn't made them
feel guilty about that they don't feel
like they can do that anymore now to be
fair a lot of their models are underage
and I think they should not do that no
no no we should have people in their you
know 18 in their 20s showing off product
and making products look appealing and
nice I think that's good marketing sure
sure what I'm saying is a lot of people
don't realize when they go to the mall
and they're walking past these mall
stores with these women those women are
like 15 years old girls are I worked as
a as a gene model briefly when I was
like you know 181 19 and most of the
competition was like 15 to 17 that's
messed up it's just weird was it
Victoria secet I mean it's like when
when when they're doing La underwear
stuff it's it is everywhere it is
everywhere it is the biggest it is the
is the major the major agencies the
international agencies they get 14 15
year old girls to do underwear modeling
it's it's it's messed up they shouldn't
do that it's worldwide okay so last
thing about makeup which you'll find
interesting the reason I've had
production delays is because every
company that I start to purchase
materials from instead of coming from
Canada it all comes from China and I
even busted them on the tracking they
were so bold as to issue me a tracking
label where it was coming from Beijing I
was like why is this taking so long why
is this taking so long so we're on our
third round right now do you are you
okay with it being produced in China or
I was trying to find something produced
in Canada the United States just not
China yeah and they were like no to the
point of the article though now like
celebrities are having a a really hard
time not talking about stuff like this
and there's just so many of them I'm
like you would do so well to just not
you don't have to have a stance on
everything was it Alicia Keys yes she
she said she wanted to go paragliding
like I have no I have no idea what her
politics are if that's true or not if
that is like a coincidence it's the
worst coin she posted on Instagram what
would you do if you weren't afraid I'd
try paragliding and then she posted the
side eye Emoji which like the side eye
emoji makes it what she saying we should
not kill people why should but then but
then she responds with like an Instagram
story she's like oh I didn't mean that
like I pray for this girl was testing
the water she wanted to see what would
happen and that's it because we know
that there are a lot of young more
radical left Ling people who are backing
Palestine in this and that's what she's
doing she's seeing a response and we
know black lives matter foundationally
wants to end Israel other people they
align themselves with are are falling
onto certain sides I mean with Huda
Beauty I wouldn't be surprised if now
you get a whole wave of young women who
are like I'm specifically buying her
products because I also believe in that
that's the thing about all the virtue
signaling is that really bigger than
just a large Market especially if you're
already established right does does
Alicia Keys benefit does her music
benefit from making to make a post like
that when you're already mainstream
established like just stay out of what's
T Swift doing she has the best marketing
she is just dating a football player and
staying in her l Bud Light and is uh
sponsored by fizer but to what you said
earlier like what you were talking ear
like all the news is like crap and it's
it's it's war and it's death and I was
like no because there was like a really
funny article the other day where some
poor People magazine person had to write
a headline and said like Taylor Swift
has now held Travis Kel's hand twice in
public some poor lady had to write that
it's like we're in middle school I saw
that post and then immediately messaged
it on Instagram to some of my friends
that I went to see Taylor Swift with
being like they're holding hands she got
four she got four years in Jay School
$8,000 in debt and they're like wow
holding hands twice right it up it's
like we've now gone like like like the
amount like time you have to spend
talking about her because like every
institution and every business has tried
to like weasle their way into her life
no one more rentree and everyone's head
Taylor Swift I'm not I'm not a fan but
man I wish the news was consumed with
Taylor Swift and not people dying in
Israel all domestic issues are I don't I
don't understand why look when I see the
Taylor Swift hate I'm like it's
like dude you have no re no there's no
reason to hate her like I oh for sure
yeah it's just like people ragging on
her and I'm like she's a popstar like
she's dancing on stage I saw someone
saying that that she must be doing
horribly if she was dating a
professional athlete no everyone else is
like I'm super I'm super her tour is
like it's like a mass 2.2 billion
already her movie made something
ridiculous amount of money like Taylor
is doing fine aspire to be on her level
of calm right now and like people are
like you guys you guys keep talking
about her like we don't I don't want to
I have no desire to talk about her but
she's relevant in almost every like how
old is she 33 33 I'm very interested in
her marketing follow that pretty closely
oh no that's that's the thing that they
already she's eligible in 2024 she'll be
she would be 35 on a on inauguration day
stay out of inauguration day oh so Janu
January 20th is her birthday she would
no but she but she will be she before
that she will be 35 by inauguration day
they point B got eled to stay stay out
of politic I've talked about how I long
for the Donald Trump speakership of the
house how that would be so amazing but
there is a like if anyone who is if God
or the simulation aliens whatever you
believe in could bring about this like
radical libertarian Taylor Swift Arc
where she just starts coming out being
like I don't even understand why we're
engaging in these Foreign Wars I'm going
to run for president and then wins you
like that she's about to go on a global
tour right so she has a chance to really
develop her diplomatic skills I think
this is a great idea okay I like Taylor
Swift as her Diplomat I like that no but
like could you imagine just all of a
sudden right like in mid 2024 she taking
this like very political libertarian
streak and she would have to marry
Travis Kelce then because then it would
be like this this uh blonde pop star
with the football player running for the
White House I don't see any regime
change under her leadership I I see
concerts there's some great Taylor Swift
for president conspiracies I I I invite
everyone to go read
them they are fantastic I will be
reading I just think she's really doing
a service to All fathers in the country
right now giving their daughters a
reason to watch football with them she's
strengthening the family she's doing
everything there's hilarious posting
ones in chat like no I don't care I'm
here for a good time not for a long time
you
know yeah exactly we're speaking into
existence say no I don't think she'll
run from I'm I'm saying if like I could
wish upon a star and it would come true
it would be like Taylor Swift Allon
comes out with very pragmatic and like
logical political stances anti-
intervention
balanced budget responsibility
individualism and then wins do do
leftist girls like Taylor Swift yeah
Everyone likes Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
did a whole thing she crosses the eye
you don't want to people like her the
girls who like Taylor Swift have the
views of Taylor Swift if Taylor Swift
came out right now and said no more
funding I mean look Taylor Swift very
likely could come out because of like a
leftist view and say no funding for
Israel and then you'd get every
15-year-old girl being like no my Isel
just scream at the top of their she said
she could do this she could say think we
should invest uh money abroad and all
the all the young girls be like mm well
Taylor said you know what I like it how
the hell did we get on this like I just
I get done with my show I've escaped
this news and I'm back here I didn't
bring this up this is this is this is
not my fault you brought it up I think I
brought it up I don't even like I can't
escape it we're talking the point is
these high-profile leftists are willing
to sabotage their entire careers for
their values they care right is not they
care more than the right the right has
to care more
people have to get out there and make
themselves vulnerable and just do it
yeah this is crazy I mean this post from
her and then we'll we'll talk about
something else but she's like I don't
know if you've noticed but Israelis from
all over the world love your products
this is from one of the fans and she was
like so remember this says no Israeli
buys from you again anywhere in the
world Gaza doesn't have money to invest
in in my opinion because they prefer to
invest in weapons but have a lovely day
she says I don't want blood money there
you go she's saying listen listen she is
she is she has no problem telling all of
her fans that if you if you are Jewish
if you are Israeli and you are
uninvolved in just a regular civilian
and you decide well Israeli okay and you
decide not to buy a product she doesn't
want your blood money so an Israeli
civilian mining their own business goes
to a store and says well you know I'm
not sure I want this she goes your
money's blood money she's saying the
money of any Israeli civilian is blood
Money pretty harsh she's coming out with
a bold stance you know pretty and this
and this the left has done this for ages
right there's a lot of people say if you
don't like my politics don't buy my book
don't buy this don't buy that like they
have no problem turning away customers
if they don't believe that they fall in
line ideologically with them you're
right yeah no they'd rather have the
customers that fall in line with their
views they have rabid rabid followers
and and loyal followers yeah I mean the
thing is whether her makeup Empire
career crashes Burns is sort of
irrelevant to me it's more interesting
that she would say anything at all I
agree exactly why we've got to jump to
this story this is huge huge breaking
news ladies and gentlemen from
newsweek.com Alex Jones warns of
possible terrorist attacks in the US I
can't believe it that's crazy of all the
people Alex Jones saying this I mean if
Alex is saying it you know this this is
a shocking thing for him to say it must
be true yeah well loves him they trust
him implicitly let me just ask this
question first I want to say this yeah
Alex is correct there's there's a fear
considering the the open the forest
border and what's going on with Israel
and and Hamas there could be Terror
attacks but I just why is Newsweek
running a headline Alex Jones warrant of
Terror attacks this is definitely one
journalist on their desk who's like I
got to get to my last story of the day
please say so let me let me Newsweek has
actually been very friendly to me and I
think they've been pretty good of all of
the the mainstream corporate media
Outlets I think Newsweek is the most
Libertarian friendly I yeah well they
they've got uh uh is is is baa still
there cuz she's fantastic I don't know
they they they've given uh uh they've
they've given a lot of push back to the
the manipulations from the The
Establishment narrative they publish a
lot of my op-eds I have a lot of opsol
no I like I'm just wondering like you
know Alex Jones warns of ter attacks
quite a bit yeah he does you know I mean
like maybe there was something about
this particular terror attack give any
more details Alex give any more details
let's see yeah they say that because of
a Hamas attack on Israel that uh uh
America has the same problem Hamas LED
blah blah blah blah blah Jones without
offering evidence told Ben he feels it's
only a matter of when not if there's an
attack on the US similar to what Israel
experienced I love how they do this
without offering evidence yeah here's my
evidence what was it four Iranians
captured the southern border and 200 or
so people in the terror watch list
that's evidence yeah there have been
multiple arrests of Americans who have
been radicalized in major cities in the
last year I remember one was a white guy
from Maine who took a bus to New York or
and and uh stabbed someone and he said
it was you know he he was Islamic and
this is this is what he had to do for
his whatever right of
passage that doesn't seem like nothing
right this doesn't happen out of nowhere
without evidence would mean he has just
arrived on the planet and he's never
been involved in American politics too
bad all the US taxpayer dollars went to
build Israel's Iron
Dome we don't have that here we don't
need that we don't even need a wall
because that's how good the Biden
Administration is
fantastic yeah I mean uh I don't think
Israel would exist without US Dollars
obviously that is not my problem yeah
that is so not my problem it's not the
problem of anyone in the United States
for us to be funding any other countries
either
and nope and yet they're all like please
more money immediately you know that
scene in parks and R where the girls
like more money please and they like
just give her some so she'll go away
yeah I wonder if they would change the
way that they behave if they did not
have the United States
dollar I don't think they would exist
they wouldn't Israel yeah I don't think
they wouldn't exist that without the
Iron Dome they they you would not be
able to live there well okay they've got
it now let's just cut them off you know
yeah but like maintaining the iron
Daddy's trust fund well you know get cre
don't they don't they create tons of
pharmaceuticals including hormones and
they do they do and they also do a lot
of surveillance technology and uh I
think they do a lot of um military Tech
stuff as well they're very smart they
figure it out did you see that story
that was in the new Zeal says like I'm
trans and I support Palestine but Israel
creates my home that's from 2018 but I'm
saying but it was like a like a Timeless
yes a Timeless tale Timeless t t is
oldest time I mean it was a great uh
insight into the the fact that this has
been a long raising tension within super
Progressive communities in the US right
this isn't something that just I I think
that's what bothers me most about all of
this is that it's not like on October
7th Hamas just attacked out of nowhere
this has been building for a long time
and in fact we know that because our own
political circles are having trouble
reconciling when they share certain
opinions with people but also disagree
on is anyone trying to do trying to just
engage Hamas in talks even if it's not
peace talks just hey way there was there
was the uh pizzaa from oh maybe Jordan
is I was thinking about the Catholic
leader that's based the the patriarch of
Jerusalem Saudi Arabia very hard to get
them on the phone I think Saudi Arabia
having a meeting with Hamas let me check
that's good someone needs to do that
keep calling but again like Hamas would
have to be open to it and I don't know
that that's tomas's top priority now
because they are not motivated for peace
because they're motivated they did reach
out they did Reach Out initially I
believe um almost initially but after
that I haven't heard anything else about
it so oh okay well the the the the the
larger story is that is uh Israel
Israeli and Saudi leaders were going to
be meeting to have peace talks and then
Hamas fired a bunch of rockets now it's
off and now it's off now it's off
someone needs to be aggressively trying
to talk to these people I don't even I
don't even think I'd start with calling
it a peace talk but maybe a what the
hell talk can we have a what the hell
talk I mean when we had Max Blumenthal
here he basically said that the reason
Hamas attacked Israel is because Israel
was having these normalization
conversations and they didn't want it
yeah I'm like they're evil yeah that's
Max is Max really knows his stuff he's
very good on foreign policy yeah but
he's you know he's very Pro Palestine
he's outright saying like Hamas engaged
in these these actions targeting
civilians and and and and killing people
because they were trying to stop peace
in the Middle East out of desperation
yeah well because peace in the Middle
East for them is a loss right like they
don't want peace in the Middle East
because they don't want a two State
solution Maybe I'm Wrong in
misinterpreting this but the the thing
that Israel or other countries might
present as peace is still considered not
satisfactory it seems incredibly
disgusting and unsavory and unbelievable
for us to like kind of have to wrestle
with this right now but when you look
back throughout history and you look at
things like the USS Liberty and the
bombing of Pearl Harbor there are things
that are highly suspicious that our
government has had Intelligence on 9/11
and then maybe it happened anyway and so
there's a real argument as to how much
they knew it's not out of the question
that Israel might have known what was
going to happen and allowed it to happen
I don't I don't know for sure that
that's the case but it's not
inconceivable but I do think it's highly
improbable and I asked Max about it and
Max also disagreed he said that Israel
is uh has this very serious I forgot
what you call a military Doctrine where
they will shoot to kill their own
soldiers if they're being captured by
Hamas that's how much they do not want
Israeli soldiers to be captured by Hamas
oh the idea that they would allow
hundreds of civilians and soldiers to be
captured is is unquestionable how did
they miss an attack when they have such
High Sur the guy who came out and said
something and spoke for Hamas said that
they had only spoken about between like
three or four of the top individuals
within so like yeah it was all it was
all like super Hush Hush on purpose
because they know they can catch up on
them and and not just that a lot of
people are pointing to Egypt having
warned Israel 10 days prior if that's
evidence and it's like dude if someone
comes to you and says hey man something
big might be coming like keep your
security up you'll be like okay does it
mean you know that like a bunch of dudes
are going to break into your garage and
steal your car right no no I I I I think
it's possible I think I think there's a
possibility that Israel there C
suspicious I think it's suspicious and I
think people should be open to it but I
do think there should be evidence before
we make you know sweet it's
substantially less likely the the
argument is that the the political uh
state of Israel has been in disarray
there's been massive conflict and
protests and this this conflict has
resulted in you know Netanyahu getting
people ring around him but I don't agree
with that because if you look at the the
collapse of the peace agreements
Israel's on the verge of making a whole
lot of money and getting a whole lot of
influence in the region if these peace
talks go through it all falls apart
right now I I I think more likely Hamas
caught him off guard they didn't expect
it to happen and they retaliated and now
they've just lost this tremendous
opportunity I mean the idea that they
were going to have economic
normalization was about to make the
region substantially
wealthier gone so you know when I think
about it I'm like I don't see the
Israeli leadership as ideological as
Hamas though I do see them as more
ideological than we would expect someone
to be yes more more ideological than we
are here in United States especially
zionists overt zionists but uh I think
for the average person Money Talks BS
walks I think for Hamas that's not the
case I agree so when it comes to what
seems to make the most sense a lot of
very very wealthy people who are Israeli
have lost a lot of money over this
happening and I really don't see the
nepotism and the elitism allowing
something like that to happen like I I
don't see them going and being like we
know this might happen and all of our
most wealthy connected families are
going to lose lots of money over it I
I'm they're probably the phone calls
came in I'm sure billionaires screaming
in faces serious threats I will end your
political career how did you miss this I
really doubt some billionaire was like
well I'm going to lose 100 million
tomorrow but it's okay I don't I don't
think so but everyone is rallying around
Netanyahu sure I mean that that that
happens there are a lot of people uh
that I've talked to about it where
they're like you know I I know someone
who's got like a wealthy family that
they're Israeli but they live in New
York or whatever I'm like I don't think
these people wanted to lose massive
portions of their net worth no certainly
not yeah I don't think they're that
ideological Netanyahu may may may see
some benefit from this but I ultimately
think it's going to cost him
substantially politically like at the
very least he's going to owe a lot of
people a lot of stuff and not just him a
lot of people in the Israeli government
who missed this do we know how long he's
been in office now oh man it's like 16
years a really long time he was out of
office for a minute there right he like
got reelected right M yeah I can look it
up 16
years from 96 to 99 and from from 2009
to
2021 yeah for a long time it is hard to
get rid of a wartime
president yeah and then and they're in
war quite a bit Minister yeah but I
guess the bigger question is was Alex
Jones right I guess we find going we
have a jar here that says he is all the
time yeah it's got a lot of money in it
yeah relative to you know a really big
jar uh it is there's also a lot of fake
money I was say I think most of that
money is fake there's some real money in
there is there some real money in there
there's like prop stacks of $100 bills
in there I always always tell people cuz
like uh on on the show on on PCC we have
the the money guns I was like we can to
put like five real $100 bills in there
and say anybody wants to help clean it
up like you can keep the real 100 if you
find you you should get an Alex Jones
with right jar and put it on the table
and then when the money go goes off
you're like trying
to trying to catch the money there I
mean I think this statement is not
specific enough to say whether he's
right or wrong because probably it will
happen um it's no shame shade to
Newsweek journalists I also sometimes
struggle to get a story out at the end
of the day but I would like to have seen
more specific I just thought it was
funny they would also deny the evidence
anyways but it's but it's just Ronda
santis said the same thing and uh so you
know Kevin MTH said the same thing it's
not surprising that Alex Jones is now
saying the same thing when uh when Alex
predicted the you uh the Russian
invasion in Ukraine everybody started
losing it being like dude he several
months ago he warned this is going to
happen like almost specifically in over
like to the te and uh you know I was
talking to him about it because we had
that event and he was like he's like Tim
I just read the news like I I don't know
he was he was basically like everyone
was surprised he got it right he was
like there's a bunch of news stories
about it like doing but it's because
there's a caricature that he's just this
loud dumb guy who screams on YouTube or
whatever like a lot of people mainstream
and left leaning don't know anything
about him so the fact that he would get
anything right is just shocking to him
because they only know him as this guy
who gets everything wrong and he says he
crazy things but you know we have to do
this uh I don't care I don't care about
politics show I don't care I just found
out about this and I want to talk about
it from defect. comom is Ronda santis
wearing hidden platform heels inside his
Studio stupid ugly boots and
investigation okay this is real Journal
I know about this we're going to get
president short King this has been going
this this this has been a story for a
long time and I have no idea how a year
now this story's been around and I did
not know about even I knew about this
one and then uh uh Ashley stclair posted
a video which clearly shows Ronda santis
wearing super tall lifts with fake toes
and I'm like dude his those are fake
like do we have do we have video of high
heel walk someone I couldn't find any
because it's like just the the last
minute but apparently people were were
were tweeting at me that there's video
of him high heel walking high heel
walking or drunk girl in high heel walk
like there's there's the 900 p.m. and
then there's the 3:00 a.m. like clunk
clunk he's been practicing this for a
long time he slings them over his
shoulder as he's leaving this is an
article from o from just two a week and
a half ago and uh they show these videos
where I mean look at this this is the
one that I saw from oh you can't PA it
that's stupid look at that his his toes
are clearly not in the front of the boot
and they they have massive platforms
this is what Ashley I saw Ashley St
Clair repost and then like look at this
right here so there's no there's no foot
right there yeah that's these are his
these are his like live laugh love
pumpkin spice fall he's he's going for
the he's going for the Hobby Lobby
demographic right now and then I love
this one with the fur this one I think
is
right it's honestly like the argument
the femur is the longest bone so why is
his fibula which would be his second
longest bone so weirdly disproportioned
like what is Donald Trump going to do
with this high heel high heel Ron I
don't know but like some of the some of
the that's weird look there there's
clearly no foot in the front of that
boot yeah look at that it's like look
how it's vent what if he just has very
very thin toes very very th before and
afters of him in regular shoes where
they look normal so is like I have
really bad arches it's just I want to
see the foot why is he wearing cowboy
boots anyway okay fine you're allowed to
wear cowboy boots but look at this right
here I did not know about this look
there's no foot there there's no way
there's a foot in that now this outline
is very silly I don't think that's
correct either but clearly those shoes I
mean look the best case scenario I can
say for him is that Jack Anatomy he
wears he wears size 12 boots cuz he's
got size seven feet and he's embarrassed
about it worst case for him is that he's
got high heels on I the thing is I've
been trying to figure out how tall he is
and I've seen everything from 5'7 to 511
and the fact that there's not just one
one statement and this guy could just be
like I you 51 and have a size seven shoe
yeah does he have a five like no I don't
I don't think so I don't know about that
that's like as somebody who is as
somebody who's short 55 he's he's really
missing out on representing me when he
yes like he needs he he lost my vote
like I would have been perfectly happy
to give this guy my vote it's the Tom
Cruz vote okay the thing is we just need
to figure out how tall his wife is and
then do the thing where you take an
object that you know the size of and
compare the difference um internet slle
could solve this we just need to be
insure ured that she's not wearing heels
and he's not wearing boots Florida they
went to the beach together this this is
a story from February 14th of this year
Dem Democrat opposition researcher slams
his hand for wearing high heeled boots
imagine being that Oppo they're called
cowboy boots I went to college for this
so this person noticed something weird
and said to santis wears high heeled
boots to appear taller but this is the
clever thing in these photos there is a
lift on the boots so they can go they're
cowboy boots with a natural heel on them
they're not high heels calm down but
what they're omitting from the the the
people arguing in favor of them they're
omitting that no the argument is
actually that inside the boot is a lift
you can't see it's a hidden lift and so
uh Matt Whitlock said tell me you've
never seen cowboy boots without telling
me touch some grass no like dude hold on
like I'm sorry I'm going to go back to
this picture right here here this one
right here bro tell me his foot is in
that right tell me he's got big flappy
pancake feet big flappy pancake feet WJ
Anatomy drawing is
correct like there's there's C boots
have a heal on them but this is not what
we're talking about here all just you
can't be you can't be a short president
these days no he's like JY duck with a
little flat internet has a bunch of
stuff saying that Casey Dan santis is
between 55 and 56 but then more recent
stuff coming out in 2023 says that she's
5'9 and so I think
someone suspicious someone uh saw headed
me off at the pass here and we're like
no no we got to make her taller too he
needs to bury that story with the Taylor
Swift marketing cuz if you look at
photos of them he's a little bit taller
than her but what did they say she was
she was saying they're saying that she's
5556 although more recent entry say
she's 5'9 so if he if she's 5'9 this is
the
dis this to get this out there she's 59
here then yes I guess he 5'11 but if
she's 5'5 then he's like 5'8 maybe I'm
telling you maybe that's why he won't
come on the show because I'm 59 and if
we stood next to each other I would know
how well now he's definitely not coming
on the show well they they they have a
mandate not to allow any of their people
to come on our show why because I'm so
tall well why do you
think they're like okay but Hannah Clair
can't be on the show with me she right
is we need we need Phil on the show well
now it's definitely not happening but
yeah between Phil and I we just need to
stand strategically next to we can
figure out wow wait wait wait where did
you see that Casey was 5'9 uh I'm seeing
it I mean none of them are super
reputable sources that makes
Ron veritable right there well that's
I'm say she's probably 55 but the the
Dan santis War Room leaked the 5'9 so it
makes him look just a little bit taller
look at this picture if if she's 5'9
he's six foot he's 6 feet tall we know
he's not are Trump people running his
campaign Instagram on purpose I mean I
swear that's why I tweeted I'm like it
has to be that the people who are
working for Ron are secret Trump
supporters it's got to be right and and
and they're like they're playing the
long game there sandbag yeah because he
was he was in the lead yeah he was he
was he was leading in the prediction
Market he was leading in the polls and
then all of a sudden he started slipping
on banana peels every you know you know
remember when
he remember when Sideshow Bob was
stepping on the rakes and hitting him in
the face just like that that's Ronda sis
campaign and I'm like somebody put those
rakes there there's no way he's
accidentally just stumbled upon a bunch
of rakes on the ground it's pretty wild
that his it's okay come out with a
boring snoozy campaign video and where I
healed
and have your campaign staff and
Communications people start randomly
attacking prominent personalities who
support Ron yeah I think he should just
go for full Spike stilettos and come out
to Purple
Rain as a motan I support that idea yes
we need Prince representation yes we do
from Ron I'm not even I'm not even
kidding I think there's a strong
possibility that the communications
people he hired are pretending to
support him I think that's yeah it's
like he does every single thing that you
want you want to not do it seems like he
does so what did Ashley Sinclair say she
said he's he's a Tinder 6 feet yeah
someone commented underneath saying how
tall is he and someone said 5'11 she
said on Tinder he says 61 look as
somebody who has never like as somebody
who's 5'5 and refuses to ever exaggerate
even even to 56 like just embrace it
dude you're fine
just apparently according to the
internet the average height of the US
president is 5'10 because which suggest
the voters her slightly taller I don't
think this is real all that's because
like 200 years ago everybody was 5 I was
just going to say people have grown we
we've got one of one of the buildings on
the fistan property is an 1800s barn
housee and you're like you're I'm I'm
I'm 510 is five 10 and a half you know
got to give little extra half inch there
but I'm I'm almost banging my head in
this building cuz I'm like considered
tall for the era giant Tim pool yeah I'm
like walking I'm like I feel great he
doesn't want to go walk into North Korea
and be the same height as Kim janun my
favorite guests were Charlie Kirk and
VOS because they're both like 65 tall
and then they were like let's get a
photo together and I like I look short
everyone's like wow Tim's short I'm like
dude they're just 65 yeah you're not
short for men they are just enormously
tall yeah right right and then it's like
you know just got to wait until we can
get someone who's not so tall in here
and take a picture with them people ask
me that they're like is Tim Short I'm
like no and they're they look oh I think
it has to do with our I think it has to
do with our camera angles a bunch of
people asked me if I was short when we
went to the Miami event or they were
like you're so much taller than I
thought everyone in TV is really small
that's how we fit on your screens it's
because when they when people are used
to watching uh people on TV and they
film from their from their chest cameras
and so uh it's usually pointed upwards
towards people when they're having
conversations so they look taller and
they're so it imagine how you view the
world when you walk around and you're
looking at people and if you're of
average height you're looking mostly at
eye level sure then you turn the TV on
and everyone is in an angle looking
upward so you feel shorter than them
here in the studio the camera all
slightly above head level otherwise the
cameras would bump into our heads like
you'd see the back of you know Brett's
head and so there's a natural downward
angle so everyone makes the assumption
that they must be taller than us because
they're looking slightly downward so
what Rona santis needs to do is hire Tom
Cruz's Director of Photography who
manages to make him look normal height
and everything that he's in watch watch
him in Top Gun one where they have to
film Val Kilmer from like half half a
block away Val Kilmer sitting down Ron's
here and the podium is here and the
camera's there and it looks like he's in
front of the podium is's really tall
he's like way back way far is he going
to get reelected now that he's had this
clown show campaign he can't be
reelected he's termed out for governor
in Florida yeah oh what's he going to do
next that's why he's running for
president that's right that's sad not
play pro
basketball so sad that's why there was a
rumor was going to run for Senate yeah
which I think could have been good ah
he's going to have to retire after this
I mean that's why that's why I'm like
look man I'm not big on conspiracy
theories Congress the idea no way he'll
never get elected I mean look no that's
not true the people mooved to Florida
love the guy and they'll vote for him
and to be honest like you know I'd
probably vote for him if he was my
Congress except for the ones who were
mad that he was running for president
yeah no actually I take that back I
don't know I mean I think after doing
this poorly I don't know if I'd even
vote for him for congress I think he's
gonna have to maybe Fade to the back for
a little bit I mean my thing is I don't
like to short the conservative bench
right like he did do things in Florida
that people loved and felt strongly
about and so I don't think that we
should just like wreck everybody right
now and then make it to they can never
have a political career but I think not
over shoes I mean look he could just
come out and then he gets sponsored I
just wouldn't vote for him because he's
GNA pump and dump a bunch of money into
Israel yeah that's that's my current
problem would he have a place in any
type of like in a in a cabinet somewhere
I mean that's the thing I if his
relationship with the presumptive
nominee Trump were to get better in the
next 12 months maybe but it's such a
long road I I just think it's hard to
say that like this time next year when
we're a month out less than a month out
from the election you know will they be
on better terms put him in charge of the
Department of Education maybe could be
interesting um but I don't like the idea
that we're just like attacking all of
our talent in primary season and making
impossible to think long term well then
maybe he shouldn't wear high heels well
you know he's doing his best to look
trustworthy and Tall uh I love that
height privilege is Alive and Well in
America some things you just can't can't
get you're not just not born with it all
right I'm I'm pulling up Ashley St
Clair's tweet I sent this to you right
is this the one wait wait hold on she's
got a bunch of videos where's she's
there
yeah okay POV your Ronda Sanz getting
ready to go
[Laughter]
out I think it's funny that she has
those the KN has well she's so cute and
so
stylish they she probably Bor them from
andess why is she wearing like blue
Power I love it love questioning that is
nice so the disis campaign actually
responded to her saying POV you have
nothing substantive to criticize
disantis on as another planet of
Americans arrives home from Israel and
it's just like they couldn't even come
back with something py and funny yeah
that was so but like but you're supposed
to roll with the punches not get angry
about it espe topics um he would only
wear cowboy boots thank you Ashley he
it's like he picked oh she apologized
here you go first apology video uh I
made a joke about Ron DeSantis there's a
very popular meme going around that
DeSantis wears heels very high
heels uh and I made a joke I put on my
stilettos and I said POV your Ronda
Santa is getting ready to go out I
thought it was funny many people thought
it was funny I make jokes about everyone
Trump the
Santa but the dantas team didn't think
it was funny and that's what's most
important so I want to from the bottom
of my heart and they said it wasn't a
very substantive
criticism and they also notified me that
just santis doesn't wear stilettos he
wears cowboy boots So Not only would I
like to apologize but I would like to be
accurate I would like to correct the
record and do this again so take two POV
your run de scentist getting ready to go
out
[Laughter]
see that's the one I'm like I can't
believe she owns
[Music]
those I like that she doesn't cut off
the end she just leaves her like hitting
stop on record this is this exemplifies
one of the problems of the Tannis
campaign they are like the nerdy yeah
loser kids who don't have a sense of
humor can't when she made the high heels
thing the response on the campaign
should have been to joke along with her
yeah absolutely and then like post a
picture of Ron wearing like like Moon
boots on the moon or something and like
he should have he should have gone run
with that song and she beat him to it
that's that's the obvious thing yeah sad
no it's just because they're incredibly
defensive I think because they feel
insecure I mean this I think they're
sabotaging him oh like like unless Ron
you know he's like going through his
resumes of people for communications and
then then he's like well none of this
works so he went down to the Lo he went
down on the highway and saw someone
holding up a sign being like hey you
want to handle my social media for me
and they're like okay and that's what
that's we got well you can't tell the
difference at this point so it is what
it is and it's like it was after like
the at the debates when he's like I will
never let you down he did the weird
smile so uncomfortable like he's never
smiled before in his entire life his
first time figuring out how to smile in
public at the same time but you got you
got to roll with them Trump has that
that there's that famous clip where he's
like the light they're too bright they
make me look orange and it's hilarious
it because we call him orange but he
doesn't care he thinks it's funny and
then he he makes it into a joke and
everyone laughs and they like it Mary
believes he's anti he's he's antifragile
when it comes to cringe he can't be
cring I want you to imagine this okay
imagine you're you're in a high school
classroom and Ron is sitting in the
corner and he's very studious and he's
writing and then he just rips out an
awful fart and then everyone looks and
they're like oh Ron did you fart and
then immediately there's three kids R
away why why do you care so much do you
have no real reason to crize him he
didn't fart you farted you're a farter
and you're like what is what is going on
then compare Trump on the other side of
the room and he goes I did it I did it
ooh smell it and then everyone's
laughing and Trump's the overconfident
arrogant Class Clown yeah who makes you
smell his farts and Ron's the guy who
who has a crew around him just denying
that a fart ever happened Trump won a
ton of people over on on Twitter when he
was retweeting memes of himself as as a
wrestler that was like the best part I
just love the uh when he was what did he
say about diet that the diet coke tweet
like I'm still going to drink that
garbage oh
yeah yeah he's like you never you never
see a thin person drinking diet coke
he's like I'm still going to drink it
he's he's very funny he's very funny is
he is really funny oh well ashle saying
CL was funny too she was kind of putting
on a little Trump impression there all
right we're going go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member by going to Tim
cast.com and clicking join us there's
going to be a members only uncensored
show coming up for you in about 25
minutes you don't want to miss it as a
member you can actually call in and talk
to us and be on the show here we go we
got quisby Joe he says am I the first
good sir you are you win the prize of
being the first Super Chat I love this
race great job everyone's fighting to
try and get the first Super Chat in and
so we're going to end up having like 50
super chats all instantly at 7:40 I
wonder if there's a way to to no I don't
think we're allowed to reward people for
doing it though I think it gets like
like sweep steak SLS or something yeah
you can't do that know we know that
you're doing a good job yeah you could
but it's you know you're first there's
only like 30 something States I I just
went through this whole thing we're
doing we're trying to do a football
Square oh really so annoying all the
different laws that that's the other
thing too like we're trying to figure
out how to do this like grant program
where we Grant members money for
projects and our lawyer is like you
can't do it and we're like we'll know
because it's like it's it's a it's a
sweep Stakes basically it's a sweep
Stakes you can do it in certain States
but not all of them and there's like
there there are ways to do it but the
problem is so long not in West Virginia
the issue is that we we want to support
our members yeah who are working on
cultural projects with a grant but they
can't be our members if we're going to
do it because then the argument is we're
just what what is it um solicitation for
a sweep Stakes if you're doing if we're
claiming it's a grant through an
external company like so if we said we
will give you you know 10 grand towards
your project sweep Stakes okay well we
we have an Investment Company and
solicitation for a sweep Stakes you like
you can't do it Rous that's weird yeah
so the only way to do it is to give any
random person it has to be completely
open to anyone anywhere basically and
I'm like okay that's probably fine like
we could probably do it that way but
we're still working through the
paperwork with our lawyers to figure out
how to do it yeah we've done some stuff
that's just not public where we've given
money to various projects people
fighting for culture War causes and
issues as well as like people who have
you know like I've I've done I've given
a lot lots of like various giv and goes
and stuff like that but you know all
right where we at salty tin man says
will the attention-driven media launch
us into World War yes thank you for your
question uh Clint Tores says howdy
people howdy but you are number three
today Clint you are not number one
slipping slipping and we
notice Ben hanock says I am one of the
Marines stationed at the US Embassy in
Jerusalem I have been watching all of
this unfold from the ground since day
one needless to say has been a crazy
week and a half wow man thanks for
tuning in from stay sa stay sa stay safe
man Michael Leo says 18 USC
2339b providing material support to a
foreign terrorist organization does
sending 00 million to Gaz account as
providing material support for Hamas
what about donations from all these
protesters let's just say yes lock them
up lock them up lock them up lock them
up you know I'm I'm trying to file for
conservatorship of Joe Biden so maybe
you won't get a chance are you really
doing that because you should yes that's
hilarious paperwork is drafted I just
need the I just need the right attorney
to file it are you serious I'm 100%
serious that's so funny and Mitch
McConnell
yes you should definitely do that yeah
conser what a fun twist that would be I
would put that in the through a strange
legal loophole uh it was court was
granted and the judges like look my my
hands are tied I the law is clear I had
the I have the libertarian party trying
to file cuz in DC a corporation or an
organization can do it we're in in you
can file conservatorship on a random
person well we have a relationship he's
the
president this is amazing I plotted this
creativity yes yeah fun does that mean
you have to go to Delaware then and hang
out with his dogs get bit hey it's not
their fault they're in a high stress
environment and and no one is taking
them out of it it's obviously correct
for
them federali actual says everyone needs
to realize that when you're wrong about
things like the hospital average people
like me will never trust you again I've
lost trust in everyone but the timcast
crew and post-millennial human events
daily their sop is legit well I mean I
wouldn't be so extreme like you can't
trust them ever again but my point is
it's really easy not to get it wrong
when you don't pick a side right so when
this story comes out we're like it looks
this way but we're not sure so check the
evidence and figure it out for
yourselves we're not trying to tell you
we know things are true if they're not
true like the barisma stuff we can I can
go through the whole list and show you
the videos and the documents and the
sorn statements and tell you what is or
isn't the hospital thing was like man we
don't even know and it turns out
Hospital wasn't even bombed right man so
I mean that's crazy that's
crazy voice the people says according to
Britannica treason is giving Aid and
comfort to enemies of the government if
Pelosi waited 71 minutes to authorize
the NG on the six the uh and the people
are enemies of the government wouldn't
that be giving Aid and
comfort potentially the the NG what is
that National Guard oh the National
Guard authorized the National Guard I
see oh I see they're trying to argue
because she told them to stand down or
something I don't think she actually did
though no I think that was earlier the
mayor didn't want it gy says Prime Time
with Alex Stein is crazy fun buck buck
buck uh yes the uh um cast bruise Alex
Stein coffee is uh uh nearing completion
so it's about to go into production so
it'll be about a month and a half but
it's uh Alex Stein's Prime Time grind
two times caffeine coffee oh nice that
totally makes sense yeah it's his
personality yes and it's him like all
excited on the bag and then um I think
we're going to be launching Ian's
graphine dream nice tell me there's no
graphine in the coffee no this okay are
there mushrooms no nope um but maybe it
should you know they have that mushroom
coffee yeah dump it in no no not Corps
that's not Corps uh no it
isps I thought this the one that was
like the one that eats your brains or
whatever no no no that's the corps is
the ant brain but yeah I'm pretty sure
the tea they they do sell is Corps huh
okay there's a few different you can get
Lion's man you can get license like a
like an Alex Stein one chip challenge
since they pulled those things from the
shelves they pulled them
yeah lawyer already like please don't
let go a kid died what they pull what
yeah di like really spicy chips that you
eat yep but like died from the chemicals
on it that he he ate it and then he went
home and then his mom took him to the
hospital and he died from eating a chip
but it was like anaphylactic shot cuz
he's allergic to the seasoning spicy it
is like one single chip in a box that's
like a ridiculous amount of spice it's
it's like an online challenge spicy like
it's like a
thing fragile Darwin
Award waste of money that's fine well no
because right here on timcast Alex Stein
ate one right right here on the show he
was fine actually he was fine yeah he
ate two I'm pretty sure so that child
isn't even as strong as Alex Stein Alex
Stein beat the child well done Alex that
is pretty good phrase though all right
coldilocks production says Don Bacon is
going to get primaried over leading the
charge against Jordan the Republican
party of Nebraska denounced him and is
looking for a competitor to challenge
him wow whoa that's crazy man they're
they're they're they're mad that Kevin
McCarthy got Ed so they're like we spite
you we won't vote for Jim Jordan it's
like just grow up dude well he was
terrible on funding now for for Israel
he mcarthy no Jim Jordan he wants to
yeah he wants to pump more money and
there's uh uh and and there's a lot of
criticism over his position on Google
and censorship and like that that's why
I'm like just just we we we booted
McCarthy out we made a statement vote
for Jim Jordan we'll all be disappointed
again and we'll move on we're always
going to be disappointed that's the way
American politics works
right okay where we at no Trump speaker
Allen uh sh Sher the boy who cried wolf
is an excellent tale it teaches the
value of not telling the same lie twice
ha oh snap that's a good one Taylor
Swift speaker of the house I mean I'd
vote for a secretary of state actually
but but like I'm saying that one day she
just comes out and she's just like I
hate the two- party system they're both
corrupt The Establishment is ripping up
everybody off these Foreign Wars are a
waste of taxpayer dollars so when she
sits in the box with Travis Kel's mom
she like have you heard about the mis's
ccus actually not even nice imagine
imagine she's on stage and then she's
just like she wraps a song up and then
in between she starts talking about
wasted taxpayer dollars foreign spending
and then all of a sudden all the
middle-aged dads who were there were
like wa wait wait what did she say
she's like she's got a big Ron Paul
poster in the back back start awkwardly
prove to me that she doesn't she when
she made one post about registering
people to vote she got 35,000 people to
sign up to vote we all every single one
of them is going to vote Democrats no no
we we what we need to do is we need
someone to just create satirical uh
videos from her events with big Ron Paul
banners yes yes like next to on stage
yeah we're doing deep fakes deep fakes
happing just I support this a real video
of Taylor's performance but like super
impose Ron Paul in the background Ron
Paul Dave Smith we'll put in put in some
more timely like new people too we'll do
a bit where she introduces Dave Smith
using AI technology I like it oh my gosh
she'll be like my future president Dave
Smith I know he's not running she who is
running a new song called End the Fed we
spent all of our time talking about s
Sho we got we have time tell me who's
running for president for for you guys
uh we well we haven't picked yet we've
got Michael rectenwald we've got Mike
termont we've got Lars mapstead Chase
Oliver and Josh Smith can you are you
endorsing someone specifically or are
you not allowed to as like it's not that
I'm not allowed to I'm trying to hold
off on that until until it gets a little
it's not in good form for the chair of
the party I certainly do have a favorite
and I think he think he he might be
coming on the show soon we say that
interesting Dave
Smith is he coming on the show to guest
I think you do have I think Dave Smith
with Michael M PR secretary was just
like so excited beautiful beautiful
we're still we're still trying to get
malice to be press secretary maybe
either way he said what did he say one
Bitcoin per month yep he said one
Bitcoin per month that's not
unreasonable right now it's like he'd be
making like what 380 400 a year or
something like that he do it would be it
would be really beautiful if anybody
wants to sponsor Michael malice for
press secretary one Bitcoin per month
dude I will sponsor Michael mice as
press secretary I don't know if I'm
allowed to do that though is that legal
it's completely legal okay well you know
that would be that would be that would
be the greatest thing ever it would
be all right well grab some more Super
chats uh let's see noname farmer says
pretty sure chicken little convinces
other Barnyard Birds to follow him then
they're all taken advantage of by a fox
looking to benefit from alarmism oh is
that that story when I looked it up
there are like several translations and
that's one of the ones that happened
there's multiple well there you
go we will grab some more Super chats
Matt says operation war hawk is a fresh
way to revive the anti-war movement yes
Angela is leading the charge on this
thanks for having her on what is that we
have a plan with at the national
libertarian party to chase the worst
warhawks out of office we are going to
essentially terrorize them during their
primary campaign and we're leaving it
open to the state Affiliates whether or
not they want to engage the GOP at the
state level and talk to them and
potentially engage their um their
opponent in the primary season but are
you saying like you're going to be at
their events asking them questions and
like absolutely running ads Jose Vega is
not in the lp but he works with us on
all of our anti-war Coalition events and
he he disrupted a Rachel mattow event
recently it went viral on Twitter he has
also disrupted aoc's Town Halls well now
hold on there a minute he disrupted how
did he do that by yelling and calling
her a corporate shill and a warmonger
see I I I'm not a big fan of that I mean
I'm a big fan of him calling her a
corporate chill and a warmonger but in
the normal process of asking a question
and being headed the microphone and
saying sure he's done both he's done
both yeah I don't I don't like the just
yelling because that actually I think
creates NE
I think this is how I think this is how
conservatives lose that they're afraid
to disrupt here we are having that same
conversation I think afraid to push the
the over the window but but that's not
it I mean if you walk into a group of
people who are unsuspecting and and
don't know what's going on and you start
yelling and insulting the person you
look like the bad guy so this is like
persuasion 101 what you call someone you
are perceived as is like one of the
first things you have understand in
doing a sales pitch I hear you I I
respectfully disagree on this one
depending on the context it can be done
right and it can be done wrong the right
way to do it would be you stand up to
ask a question and then you ask a simple
question an answer for it but that is
not the the end all BAL of operation
Warhawk removal that's just that's just
a tiny part we're going to be doing
aggressive billboard campaigns we're
going to be running libertarian
candidates against them but the the
aggressive media attack is in the
primary season it's meant to really make
them feel the pain and try to push push
a different Republican into office as
well cool that sounds great it'll be fun
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats Isaac Gorski says it was all a lie
peace has crumbled and Joe is rewarding
them time to stop paying taxes to a
corrupt government that serves enemies T
well look man I don't think I I wouldn't
necessarily agree with that I say pay
your taxes but um do what you can to get
the people you support into office and
the local level is the most important
thing everybody's ignoring their state
senators and state reps and that's where
all the laws are actually being made and
if you want to figure out how you win
your District like oh man I live in this
District and it leans like Democrat Five
Points like okay well why don't you vote
for your local legislators so that way
they can drop the maps and then get a
more favorable map so that your federal
representative more represents your
values okay really good really good
comment on that my my friend Cody wck is
on city council and the City of lonar he
recently fired a government employee and
saved the city a ton of money hey that's
great it cost on a small town like that
with five with 5,000 people if they see
this they'll flip out you know it costs
like a couple hundred dollars to get a
door knock for to get someone elected in
cities that are a little bit larger it
might cost you like $5,000 you can
donate $5,000 to a candidate or the
libertarian party preferably or whatever
and then you can fire a useless City
employee who's raking in a sixf figure
income if you do that over and over
again huge changes in your local
community a lot of people don't know
this too a bunch of your local
politicians run on a post MH yep that's
the craziest thing especially in Chicago
I remember looking at the Bal and it was
like unopposed unopposed and I'm like
that's
crazy somebody wanted to be the C
troller I guess there Town nearby in
West Virginia where they had to like be
like no you run for air I don't want to
do it anymore you run wow you can get
rid of employees who literally just sit
there and do nothing they collect a
paycheck I think this guy was like
smoking weed on the job something
completely out out of control outrageous
man all right where is that position
available
[Laughter]
now let's see what do we have Zane
Thomas says Israel tried giving Gaza
concrete for buildings Haman Hamas used
it for tunnels there's videos of Hamas
taking water pipes and using them to
make rockets and it's no wonder than the
Rockets misfire their propulsion systems
a break yeah because they're made out of
water pipes yeah that's crazy stuff man
and they put these videos out
celebrating it yep they want people to
see it they filmed themselves killing
civilians it's awful because they they
their their the argument is they want to
show how powerful they are or something
no I think they want Joe Biden to give
$100 million that's crazy
definitely Michael rectenwald says it's
not leftists or rtists but staus versus
anti statists I disagree I don't think
so I don't think so is he going to be on
your is he going to be a guest ever He
he'll be a great guest probably I don't
know but uh I've heard this a lot
there's there are people like the
culture war is is authoritarian versus
libertarian it's nationalist versus
globalist it's statist versus
anti-statist it's you know woke versus
unwoke and I'm just like I don't think
so he's very good on the culture board
though he used to be a Marxist and he is
aied libertarian now he's a really
interesting story the culture war is
basically like honest convers like it's
it's like logic versus disorder it is
honesty versus dishonesty it is reason
versus you know uh rage yeah you know so
it's it's it's it's not really status I
mean the left positions don't make any
sense it's like an inversion of reality
so Libertarians can have arguments with
the post liberals and the conservatives
and there's an honest conversation that
results in something some kind of move
forward the left doesn't have those
conversations I think perhaps he's
referencing people who are like you the
the principal antiwar left the dissident
left there's still some good people out
there but you know those well I thought
Max was great I absolutely Max he he was
a fantastic Max Jimmy door all of those
guys oh Jimmy dor is absolutely
wonderful too and uh it was great it's
it's it's great having Max on to because
while there's a lot of stuff we disagree
with when it comes to Pal like uh uh in
Israel like uh Phil was arguing with him
when it comes to issues of the
establishment in war we're like we
completely agree and then I'm like as
far as I'm concerned like Israel
Palestine stuff is is is out there so if
you disagree on that okay if we agree on
the corruption inside the United States
government revolving door policies
corporations Etc we're we're good like
let's let's figure this stuff out and
then we'll figure out who who's getting
I mean he'd probably agree when when the
Libertarians come out and say we don't
want to fund any foreign Nations he'd be
like done he spoke at a Ron Paul event
recently he spoke at our anti-war rally
earlier in the year too yeah he was
mentioning that and he was like you know
his point was if we disagree on a bunch
of things but we agree on on certain
things we have we have to get those
things done especially if they're the
important things absolutely yeah thank
you please and then it's also important
for a a lot of people didn't like what
he was saying and I'm like dude listen
to what he is saying right there was
there was one dude who wanted to get a
pramas rally canceled I think it's in
Texas or something yes I saw it on yeah
and I'm like no no why I I need those
videos of them supporting terrorism so I
can show my family we need to know what
they're doing well I've got family
members who are like that's not true
they're not supporting Hamas I'm like
here's a video of them doing it let's
find out let him speak please yeah let's
find out what they're doing I would like
them to say those
things yeah Ben Stark says just when we
started thinking right wiers could be
anti-war some Muslims shoot some rockets
and we're right back to wipe them off
the
map well we'll see what uh uh Donald
Trump says I have a feeling Donald
Trump's going to be more interventionist
when it comes to Israel absolutely he
was very he was very anti-idle Middle
East intervention in his first uh run
the second run he was trying to get the
troops out no new Wars I have a feeling
when it comes to Israel however he's
going to play support and and financing
Joe Biden has just positioned himself to
be the the pro Hamas president and so
czy what a strange I couldn't believe
when I saw that he flies he flies to
Israel and says we're we're giving
palestin $100 million I mean my heart
goes out to those people but I don't
know why we're essentially giving
murderous Warlords a bunch of money I
don't know know either I feel like this
is a decision a like I don't want to
sound like a like a bleeding heart
leftist but there's school lunch de in
the United States we have like VA guys
who who are suicidal the pipes in Flint
Michigan need to be fixed literally
anything except putting money in the
Middle East please I think everyone says
they did fix Flint but um Newark
Pittsburgh is a whole bunch of cities
with crumbling infrastructure abely one
place how about this 340 the highway
into West Virginia they are working on a
rock a rock slide abatement which has
resulted in route nine getting jammed up
so nobody can go south from Virginia
into West Virginia from Maryland into
West Virginia there's this little dirt
road been torn to shreds and all the
locals how about we divert some of the
money from Hamas into just that one
little local project we've got going
over I just found out about it my my
babysitter who is a great guy from the
misus caucus actually he was messaging
me he was like can I get through the 340
and I calling around I was like I guess
you can't get through the 340 they so
there's from from Maryland to West
Virginia 340 is the highway that goes
through across two Bridges it goes into
Virginia and then West Virginia and they
shut it down for three months so you
have to go from Mary Land South into
Virginia IND County and yeah inden
County and then and then you got to turn
at like it's like it comes down to a
point and then you go down and then back
up to get into West Virginia yeah and
the traffic's backed up for like two
miles M yeah because it's a three
three-way intersection and people who
are just trying to go from DC to West
Virginia are are stuck at this light
that's broken it doesn't work then
there's this little dirt road that
people who are coming from West Virginia
try to cut through and it's it's dirt so
now the road is
just
like half the road's been destroyed
completely and apparently the locals are
revolting and and I'm just I'm bringing
this up cuz I'm sure all of you
listening at home have some kind of
similar problem with construction and
diversions and we're sitting here
talking about a $ hundred million going
into Palestine after Hamas the
leadership in Gaza just killed a bunch
of Israeli civilians and we can't get we
can't get the road fixed it's like the
Pawn Shop Meme best I can do is 100
million in Ser you need your roads fixed
best I can do is give but also run for
local office or support people who are
running for a local office and just tune
out to some of imagine being the people
in Hawaii who like 100 million to to to
Gaza huh to where question you meant to
to Hawaii right no no the funny the
funny thing about our our issue is that
apparently I heard this from a local
politician that uh the people in
Virginia voted against it so basically
You' got this Tri State so it's all yeah
you know inter uh it's all negotiated
yeah and uh when West Virginia was like
we want to expand the highway going into
Virginia they said no so what happens is
the four-lane highway bottlenecks down
into a two-lane Highway and so now
you've got this massive massive traffic
jam that's disrupting all of the locals
who live there and they're the ones who
voted against expanding the road yeah
that sucks man well there you go I mean
I get it like Hey we're going to do a
bunch of construction we're going to
expand the highway it's going to take
this much time they're like no no no
don't do it and now that the other
highway is like there's going to be a
rock slide that's shut down now they're
screeching
yeah dude it's like an hour wait yeah if
you wait for the traffic and you don't
take that dirt road then you're going to
wait like yeah 30 whole life around this
yeah like I don't make I don't make time
to get out there very much anymore just
because of how much extra traffic there
is they can't clean up the rock slide so
they have to they have to like it's it's
t it's a big mountainous it's like a
mile of like mountain side rock rock
yeah rock face they've got to bolt
chains and The Rock it's not like one
rock fell and that's what they're
cleaning up they're clean it from
falling multiple Rock it's a 3mon
project and it keeps getting delayed and
then finally they're just like we're
shutting the highway down y That's
horrible yep so that cuts off West
Virginia from Frederick Maryland which
is yeah a million people or something
the total Metro major Prof Travis who
made it out to help me anyway watching
watching the baby yeah it's brutal it's
brutal all right we'll grab a couple
more of these here uh super chats but
anyway the point was can we just get
some money to fix our problems seriously
why am I paying so much in taxes to to
deal to do do this yeah makes no sense
people remember that's where your
money's
gone Alex langard says Tim it's cass's
belly not cassus belly when did I say
cassus I never heard you say cassus yeah
it's Cassis belly I know this because I
play Civilization and I know what Cassis
Bell is you just got well acted in a
Super Chat well know about that yeah
there was like another one that was
really weird where they were like it's
these super chats where people claim
things that I never said where where is
this one someone said said uh that I
claimed if Trump was kidnapped he would
talk his way to becoming president and I
was like I never said that I think I
made that joke so sorry about that you
said I don't remember that I was joking
I was not actually saying that it was
when we having this hypothetical like
you know Biden was going to Israel and
we're like why are we doing this and I
made a joke that if Trump were kidnapped
he's so he has so much Charisma he could
talk himself into a different elected
position it was a joke and it was not
that's that's the libertarian autism
can't make jokes get jokes humor does
not read humor is uh disallowed under
the current Administration it's not not
a legal thing to do I forgot that part
of the First
Amendment oh it was funny when I read
that one super chat from uh from Alan
about the boy who cried wolf he
literally wrote in parentheses it's
pronounced shower and I call I said
shower oh because I I read your name
before I read what you actually wrote
you know that's really funny but uh
shout out get your name get your name
right now to pronounced
shower all right we'll grab a uh one
more Super Chat uh here we go
that's a good one Michael a says Tim
there is literally nothing wrong with
being short I completely
agree r s i i AG you need to talk to him
I know like somebody can somebody get me
the guy's number I can I can help this
guy see confident short man to another
you just got to see early on you have to
develop a personality to make up for the
fact that you're not tall that's a tall
Order final thoughts I will say this
when I when I worked for nonprofits
there were three types of top
fundraisers three types there were two
different types of Top Male fundraisers
and one type of top female
fundraiser the uh okay so I've asked
this a lot so a lot of viewers probably
don't know the answer but um you go on
the street and you wave to people and
you ask them for money what
characteristic of men do you think led
to them having lots of signups and
donations anybody they were tall I knew
you were guys who were over six feet
always came back with loads of cash and
and and sign up forms crazy uh the
second characteristic among men was that
they were fast talkers Y and the the
Trope of the car salesman I knew a guy
who was 5'5 but he talked like Ben
Shapiro and he'd come back little the
cash listen I tell you just b b and then
he he gets it their brain just shuts off
and they say just take the money yeah
yeah hypnotizing yeah so it's like
powerful Charisma with a short guy or a
tall guy and and the tall guys often
sounded really dumb like look you know
I'm just I think you should help us out
you know and like and you are so tall I
believe you and also men 80% of the
signups men got were from women and for
women men now what was the one
characteristic among women that resulted
in the most signups wearing a dresser a
skirt
nope attractiveness short height you're
talking about height now nope was among
so top fundraiser female one
characteristic that led to them I would
say not led to but
when you would see a top fundraising
female they typically shared one
characteristic who's going to say it I
mean you know the answer right no no one
knows the it's obvious it's the most
obvious thing in the world there's a
whole restaurant indry based I know
that's what I'm saying yeah the the when
I worked at all these different offices
you're not to say this in the offices
because oh it's sexist but it's like
everybody noticed that the chicks with
big boobs would come back with tons of
money it's like everyone in chat got it
yeah I'm sure they did I was like who
who will be the one to say it we got to
go to the members show so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends go to
timcast.net
awesome you can find me on Twitter
patreon and locals Angela McArdle cool
uh I'm Hannah Clair rmo I'm a writer for
timcast you should follow timcast news
on Twitter and Instagram it's the best
you can see work from me Adrian Norman
Chris burtman everyone who's excellent
in my personal opinion if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Instagram at
Hanah Clair Duppy and I'm on Twitter at
HC brimo thank you so much guys if you'd
like to follow me I am on Instagram and
Twix Brett dvic on both of those
platforms please go and check out pop
culture crisis is Monday through Friday
300 p.m. Eastern Standard Time that is
noon Pacific Audio versions Amazon music
Apple podcast all of those platforms
come check us out guys and uh I am
surge.com I just want to keep shouting
out uh the box and to uh yeah just
encourage people that are fans at the
box to uh remember to stand strong
against England they will not take us
once more that's all all right everybody
we will see you all over at timcast.net